Die traditionellen Klänge, die jeden letzten Mittwoch hier aufrührt, ab 22 Uhr zu hören sind, das sind die Klänge vom Chaos Radio, der Sendung, die drei Stunden lang jeden letzten Mittwoch im Monat der Chaos Computer Club bestreitet. Heute vom Chaos Computer Club zugegen. Und sie stellen sich selber vor.
Frank Rosengardt, hallo.
Und Max von Malodki, der natürlich nur gastweise immer für drei Stunden Mitglied des Chaos Computer Clubs ist, aber Computer Club freundlich eingestellt ist. Das kann man ruhig so sagen. Das Thema des heutigen Abends kommt vordergründig wieder sehr technisch, hintergründig allerdings sehr sozial relevant daher und wird natürlich am besten erklärt von denen, die hier im Studio sind, nämlich von Nils und Frank.
Hallo. Also wir wollen uns heute beschäftigen mit kontaktlosen Chipkarten. Die Technologie dazu heißt RFID, nämlich Radio Frequency Identification. Und das bedeutet, dass zum Beispiel wie der bisherige Barcode auf Lebensmitteln soll dann abgelöst werden durch ein kleines Funketikett, was also die Daten, die auf dem Barcode bisher drauf sind, dann nicht mehr mit so einem Laserscanner eingelesen werden, sondern einfach per Funk übermittelt werden. Allerdings kann man da auch dann noch wesentlich mehr Daten übermitteln, als jetzt in so einem Barcode drin ist, in so einem Strichcode. Soll aber zum Beispiel auch vorkommen als Ersatz für den BVG-Fahrschein hier in Berlin, dass wir also so eine Klassikkarte kriegen, so eine Chipkarte, und damit dann bargeldlos und per Funk einfach bezahlen und damit unsere Fahrscheine lösen.
Also im Grunde eine Sache, die unsichtbar in alle möglichen Lebensbereiche Einzug halten soll, in denen jetzt andere Geschichten an der Tagesordnung sind. Sehr, sehr vielfältig einsetzbar. Die Frage, die wir jetzt am Anfang haben an euch Berlin und Brandenburg, wie weit kennt ihr sowas schon? Denn das macht im Grunde aus, wie tief wir jetzt erstmal in die Geschichte reingehen und wie viel ihr vielleicht schon wisst. Habt ihr eine Ahnung, ob irgendwo in eurer Umgebung diese RFID-Dinger schon benutzt werden? Das heißt, geht ihr vielleicht irgendwo vorbei, wo ihr keine Karte mehr durch so einen Kartenleser ziehen müsst, sondern wo ihr einfach nur vorbeigeht, irgendwas irgendwo dran haltet, sei es beim Job oder beim Sport oder wo auch immer. 0331 70 97 1 1 0. Die Nummer, für den Fall, dass ihr schon ein bisschen Kontakt damit gehabt habt oder vielleicht was gelesen habt, wo es demnächst eingesetzt werden soll. 0331 70 97 1 1 0. Hier hört das Chaos Radio auf Fritz, kurz nach 10. Die Sendung hat gerade erst angefangen. 84. Ausgabe des Chaos Radios. Alle Infos gibt es noch mal nachzulesen auf www.http.caosradio.ccc.de Und machen wir das immer noch mit der Mail?
Ja genau, wenn ihr irgendwie Fragen zu sehen habt, wenn ihr irgendwie Input habt, Sachen, die ihr uns zukommen lassen wollt, dann schreibt ihr an die 84.at.caosradio.ccc.de also 84 in Zahlen 84.at.caosradio.ccc.de Thema heute Abend ja im Grunde Subkutan.
Also sowas, was sich so versteckt von hinten an, schlecht durch die Brust ins Auge auf einmal die ganze Welt beherrschen könnte. Ein Thema, das zu Verschwörungstheorien einlädt und doch so simpel und technisch ist.
Wir haben es in einem Ankündigungstext, da habe ich Dinge auch kleine fiese Funkfreunde genannt. Das sind also, können vorkommen als kleine Millimeter große oder kleine Etiketten aufgeklebt irgendwo. Das ist also eine Technologie, die ganz, ganz klein ist, auch ein sehr unauffällige und dadurch, dass da eigentlich auch keine aktive Handlung des Benutzers mehr erforderlich ist. Das kann natürlich sein, dass es so gewünscht ist, dass jemand seine Karte gegen so ein Lesegerät hält. Es kann aber auch einfach sein, die Dinge haben mittlerweile eine Reichweite von anderthalb Metern oder mehr, dass das einfach so im Vorbeigehen irgendwelche Daten ausgelesen werden. Das ist also im Prinzip ein BVG-Fahrschein oder im Supermarkteinkauf vielleicht. Die einfach dann, ja, berührungslos, kontaktlose Chipkarten heißen die auch. Das sagt es einfach genau aus. Da ist es halt keine wirkliche Aktion mehr notwendig. Ihr müsst diese Karten nirgendwo mehr reinstecken, nirgendwo durchziehen, sondern es geht einfach so und vorbeigeht per Funk.
Um diese Teile wird es heute Abend gehen und was für Möglichkeiten und auch Missproduktmöglichkeiten es da gibt. Frank Rosengardt, den ihr gerade gehört habt, ist ja eine bekannte Stimme vom Chaos Computer Club aus Berlin. Meine Person Max Formalotky, der Nils, der ist noch unbekannt, bis jetzt ist auch das erste Mal dabei. Stellt sich vielleicht einfach mal kurz vor, weil wir haben ja hier wachsendes Personal.
Ja, Nils Leopold ist mein Name. Ich bin Geschäftsführer der humanistischen Union. Das ist immer noch die älteste Bürgerrechtsorganisation in Deutschland. Ich bin gleichzeitig auch gelernter Rechtsanwalt und ich denke mir auch vielleicht ein bisschen in der Funktion des Datenschutzfachmanns hier. Also ich bin selber in diesem Bereich tätig und möchte aber auch bürgerrechtlich natürlich gerne da auch was zu sagen zu RFID-Tags.
Wir haben einen Rechtsanwalt dabei. Ich bin so glücklich. Das ist nicht immer der Fall und es beruhigt einen zutiefst. Wunderbar. 0373 77 97 110, die ihr anrufen könnt. Wenn ihr beim Chaosradio mittalken wollt, ist es eine Talksendung, die hauptsächlich ihr bestreitet. Drei Stunden lang hier auf Fritz. Und es geht erstmal darum, ob ihr vielleicht schon mal irgendwo Kontakt gehabt habt mit diesen Teilen. Weil diese RFID, das hört sich jetzt für die meisten wahrscheinlich schrecklich neu an. Das gibt es ja noch nirgendwo. Doch, das gibt es schon teilweise an bestimmten Stellen. Und man hat es auch schon mal irgendwo gesehen in Betrieben oder bei bestimmten Sportveranstaltungen. Alles, wo viele Leute irgendwo durchgehen, wo irgendwas irgendwie schnell gehen muss. Da ist gar kein Kontakt mehr vonnöten mit irgendwelchen Karten oder Barcodes oder so. Sondern da wird alles eben über Funk erledigt. Das ist meistens der Fall, wenn irgendwas nicht berührt werden muss. Also wenn ihr irgendwo durchgegangen seid und etwas nicht berührt habt, dann 0331 77 97 110.
Und bevor wir jetzt zu den Anrufern kommen, möchte ich nochmal auf unser Camp hinweisen. Wir veranstalten ja nächstes, also jetzt nicht dieses Wochenende, sondern das Wochenende danach, nämlich vom 8. bis zum 10. August, das große Chaos Communication Camp in Alt Landsberg. Und da möchte ich, dass ihr alle kommt. Das wird eine ganz riesige Veranstaltung. Das Wetter wird so sein wie heute oder noch besser. Und ihr könnt eure Computer mitbringen, eure Zelte. Und wir werden da vier Tage lang Spaß haben und Vorträge hören. Es wird viele Veranstaltungen geben, interessante Referenten und insgesamt eine recht schnuckelige Veranstaltung, wie sie auch schon vor vier Jahren hier stattgefunden hat. Wir brauchen allerdings da noch ein paar Helfer. Und es wäre schön, wer da morgen Lust hat und tagsüber Zeit hat, dass nämlich zum Beispiel das große Hackcenter ist aufzubauen. Und dann solltet ihr euch melden, bitte bei contact.camp.ccc.de Contact mit C jeweils, contact.camp.ccc.de Und dann könnt ihr dann auch erfahren, was es da noch zu tun gibt und auch wie ihr da hinkommt, mit Fahrgemeinschaften oder sowas, falls ihr kein eigenes Auto habt.
Soweit das Camp, was übernächstes Wochenende startet, ist wirklich zu empfehlen. Es kostet diesmal allerdings Geld, ne?
Ja, es kostet 100 Euro Eintritt. Da ist aber drin eine richtig fette Internetanbindung. Ich weiß nicht wie viel wir haben, 100 Megabit oder sowas von der Größenordnung. Also es hat ganz, ganz viel Internet da. Viel mehr, als ihr jemals brauchen könnt. Die ganze Infrastruktur ist da. Es gibt Vorträge, eine nette Atmosphäre. Es ist halt Camping, so mit allem Drum und Dran. Wasser, es ist ein netter See, direkt an dem Gelände dran, wo ihr auch baden gehen könnt. Und es sind eben vier Tage. Und wer Lust hat, noch einen Tag länger da zu bleiben oder einen Tag früher da aufzuschlagen, noch ein bisschen mitzuhelfen, ist natürlich auch kein Problem. Geht einfach mal auf www.ccc.de.camp.de slash 2003. Und da findet ihr auch alle nötigen Infos.
Der Frank sagt das natürlich nicht umsonst, dass eine fette Internetanbindung ist. Denn bevor im August das neue Urheberrechtsgesetz in Kraft tritt, muss man sich ja noch ein bisschen beeilen und verschiedene Sachen erledigen. Gut, 077-97-110, aber die Nummer für den Blue Moon, abgesehen davon, dass ihr beim Camp natürlich mitmachen könnt, wenn ihr möchtet. Es geht heute Abend um RFID, also Radio Frequency Identification. Und am Telefon ist der Stefan, der offensichtlich schon mal Kontakt damit hat. Hallo Stefan.
Und da haben sie diese Dinger überall an den Listen.
Und wie funktioniert das da?
Du kaufst hier unten eine Wochenkarte oder auch eine Tageskarte, ist eigentlich egal. Und die steckst du dir dann einfach in deine Hose rein oder in die Jacke. Und dann kommst du an diesen Drehkreuzen vorbei und dann halt ohne irgendwas zu machen, gehst vorbei. Dann geht es auf, dann machen wir nicht jedes Mal seine scheiß Karte raus zum Motion. Und das ist eigentlich super.
Und wären die denn irgendwie personalisierte Karten? Wären die denn speziell auf dich angepasst oder kannst du dir im Prinzip dann auch irgendwie noch deinem Kumpel geben?
Die kann man noch weiter rechnen, da passiert gar nichts weiter. Die kriegt jeder unten am Lift. Also, das ist voll praktisch. Ich meine, bevor du jedes Mal aus den Handschuhen raus und deine scheiß Karte rauskramst und die da reinsteckst.
Und bist du auch schon mal so volle Kanne mit den Eiern gegen das Kreuz gelaufen, weil es gerade nicht funktioniert?
Also ich meine, manchmal hakt es schon ein bisschen, aber dann springst du halt ein bisschen ran oder so. Oder reibst ein bisschen deine Hose an dem Ding und dann funktioniert es.
Ja wunderbar. Das scheint ja wenigstens ein Anwendungsbereich zu sein, in dem das funktioniert. Das war vorhin, bevor wir die Sendung angefangen haben, auch mal kurz zur Sprache gekommen, dass das da, wo man eben vier Bohai machen müsste, um irgendwo durchzukommen, durchaus schon gebräuchlich ist. Wie lange gibt es denn das schon?
Weißt du das?
Also ich war letztes Jahr, hatten das auf jeden Fall schon gehabt. Und beim Jahr davor habe ich es von vereinzelten Skigebieten auch schon gehört. Aber seit diesem Jahr ist es eigentlich überall. In Österreich und in Bayern.
Wird es denn nur an dem Eingang zum Skilift benutzt? Oder gibt es da auch andere Terminals? Zum Beispiel könnten wir vorstellen, dass die Apre-Ski-Party zum Beispiel, dass du damit auch irgendwie einen Freidring kriegst oder so eine Geschichte.
Habe ich persönlich noch nicht von gehört.
Und weil wir direkt mal umsteigen können, weil es offensichtlich so ist, dass abgesehen von dieser sehr prominenten Art und Weise die Teile schon zu benutzen, gibt es ja nicht so viel, wo die Leute das kennen könnten. Würdest du dir wünschen, dass der Rest deines Lebens auch durchdrängt ist mit allerlei von diesen Teilen, also dass du beim Einkaufen eben diese Text auf deinen Klamotten drauf hast, die du kaufst, dann wird das automatisch abgerechnet oder du gehst durch die BVG, da wird das auch so gemacht. Würdest du dir das wünschen?
Ja, also bei der BVG wäre es eigentlich an sich ganz cool. Aber jetzt beim Einkaufen oder so, da kann ich mir auch an die Kasse stellen.
Zahlen muss man doch, ne?
Aber mit dem Abbuchungsklub, da kann man auch noch ein Haufen Chintu damit streben, oder?
Tja, allerdings wahrscheinlich.
Ganz kurz bei der BVG, du hast es erwähnt, hast du damals zufällig an diesem Feldversuch teilgenommen?
Das wär spannend, wenn da jemand dran teilgenommen hat, Berlin und Brandenburg, ihr nehmt doch an allem teil. Wenn da jemand bei diesem Ticketfeldversuch teilgenommen hat, der BVG, was da so alles hin und her und schief gegangen ist, sofort anrufen, 031 77 97 110. Wir brauchen Probanden. Meldet euch einfach beim Chaosradio heute Abend. Dir erstmal vielen Dank, Stefan. So, da haben wir das erste Beispiel, wo das funktioniert, nämlich am Skilift, da funktioniert es natürlich auch recht gut. Die scheinen ihr System ja nicht wirklich auszuweiten. Wär ja geil, wenn es da auch noch andere Service-Möglichkeiten gäbe, das mit dem Drink zum Beispiel wäre cool. Wenn du mehr als 20 Mal mit dem Lift fährst, kriegst du einen extra Schuhstiefel oder so. Das wär schon cool. Aber was könntet ihr euch vorstellen, Berlin und Brandenburg? Wofür könnte man die Teile gebrauchen? Und wo habt ihr Angst, dass sie gebraucht werden könnten? Das ist ja auch das Thema heute Abend. Vielleicht könnt ihr einfach noch mal groß ausholen, weil es gibt ja schon viele Anwendungsbereiche, die angedacht sind, oder?
Ja, also ich hab so ein bisschen das Gefühl, es ist diesen Sommer gerade starkes Thema gewesen. Es gab vor einer Weile schon die Ankündigung der Europäischen Zentralbank, der EZB, dass sie jetzt da rumspielen wollen mit Chips, die zum Beispiel auf Geldscheine aufgedruckt sind. Das heißt also, dass Geldscheine, also jetzt nicht jeder 5-Euro-Schein, aber so die 100er und 200er und größer sollen dann mit diesen kleinen Tags ausgestattet sein. Das ist noch nicht ganz spruchreif, die sind da noch am Experimentieren. Und das hat dann, ja gut, also wenn ich jetzt zur Bank gehe, dann zahlen die mir Geld aus, zum Beispiel der Geldautomat zahlt etwas aus und registriert dann natürlich automatisch auch die Scheine, an wen man sie rausgegeben hat. Und dann gehe ich damit irgendwie einkaufen oder so, oder gebe die irgendjemand anders, zum Beispiel in einem kleinen schwarzen Koffer oder so, und der zahlt es dann wieder ein. Und dann sind die dann auch wieder registriert. Ursprünglich der Gedanke dabei war, um zu zählen oder zu sehen, wie lange Geldscheine im Umlauf sind. Also Geldscheine haben ja auch nicht eine begrenzte Lebensdauer, die ist in Deutschland oder jetzt in Europa, im Vergleich zum Beispiel zu den USA relativ kurz. Die Geldscheine werden schon nach wenigen Wochen wieder aus dem Verkehr gezogen. Die sind einfach abgegriffen, die sind abgenutzt, kommen dann in den Schredder und werden neu gedruckt. Und um da also Sachen nachvollziehen zu können, oder zum Beispiel auch beim Raub oder bei irgendwelchen großen Erpressungen oder sowas, da sind dann natürlich so Sachen auch ganz nützlich, weil man dann ziemlich schnell sieht, da muss man nicht irgendwie diese Seriennummern einscannen.
Oder Farmbomben mit verpacken.
Genau. Und das ist aus Sicht der Bank natürlich eine ganz wünschenswerte Sache eigentlich. Schon nachvollziehbar.
Hieß aber auch, dass jeder einzelne Geld schon eindeutig identifizierbar wäre.
Ja, und nicht nur das. Das Praktische ist, ich könnte mit so einem Lesegerät dann natürlich auch durch die Gegend laufen, mit so einem kleinen Handlesegerät, und dann sehen, was die Leute in der Tasche haben. Das ist eigentlich eine ganz prima Sache für einige Leute. Klar, das ist natürlich so ein unangenehmer Nebeneffekt davon, der vielleicht so nicht bei bedacht worden ist.
Aber da wir ja einen Rechtsanwalt im Studio haben, Herr Rechtsanwalt Nils, ist das denn überhaupt alles möglich, weil das ja schon ein bisschen klingt, wie der Eingriff in meine Privatsphäre, wenn solche Sachen einfach so hinter dem Rücken entschieden werden, oder nicht? Dass es so was gemacht werden soll.
Also diese Anwendung mit den Geldscheinen, die angeblich dabei der EZB auch gelaufen sein soll, als Projektidee, aber noch nicht sprachreich, das wäre natürlich eine ziemlich spektakuläre Anwendungsart, weil das dann in der Tat ja jeden betreffen würde, der eben seine Geldscheine in der Tasche trägt und damit einfach ein Problem bekommt, kontrollieren zu können, wer was von ihm weiß, also wer weiß, was er in der Tasche hat. Also jeder, der diese Scheine auslesen könnte, hätte damit umfangreiches Wissen über die Person, die diese Geldscheine trägt. Das ist schon spektakulär, weniger spektakulär, aber wohl realistischer und jetzt schon teilweise wohl in England in der Anwendung sind ja offenbar eben diese großen Nahrungsmittelkonzerne, die eben ihre Produkte mit diesen Tags ausstatten und damit die Möglichkeit haben, beim Rausgehen aus dem Supermarkt registrieren zu lassen, welche Produkte gerade rausgehen und dementsprechend zum Beispiel abzurechnen. Oder ein anderes spektakuläres Beispiel, was im Internet jetzt kürzlich auch vom Spiegel berichtet wurde, war eben die Möglichkeit, Leute, die Rasierklingen im Supermarkt kaufen, automatisch über Tags zu erfassen. Jemand, der die Rasierklingen aus dem Regal nimmt, wird automatisch von einer Videokamera erfasst. Und bei seinem Rausgehen aus dem Supermarkt wird ein Bild von ihm geschossen, weil man eben annimmt statistisch, dass Leute, die Rasierklingen mitnehmen, auch sehr häufig eben Rasierklingen mitgehen lassen, also klauen und deshalb präventiv diese Leute versucht zu fotografieren und zu identifizieren.
Ich dachte, man wollte die davon abhalten, dass sie Selbstmord begehen. Das hätt ich ja jetzt noch lustig gefunden.
Da hatte ich übrigens schon vor der Sendung eine lustige E-Mail bekommen von jemand, der in Großbritannien gerade ist. Es ging um die Supermarktkette Tesco. Er hat dann einfach mal einen Customer Service geschrieben und wollte wissen, wo er so einen Tag kaufen könnte. Die haben dann die Antwort gesagt, sie können sie nicht kaufen, aus Sicherheitsgründen verkaufen wir die nicht. Ich meinte, naja, gut, dass ich nehmen dann auch die Rasierklingen mit dazu, wenn es denn sein muss. Und dann kam wieder so, naja, sie können nicht verraten, aus Geschäftsgeheimnissen, was auch immer, wo es diese Rasierklingen mit diesen Tags gibt. Und der war dann völlig verzweifelt und dachte, naja, ich will nur Rasierklingen kaufen, sagen sie mir doch einfach, wo es diese dann gibt. Und dann kam nur so eine Standardantwort, vielen Dank für Ihre Anfrage und unser Interesse an unseren Produkten, blablabla. Und das war's dann. Also die wollten nicht damit rausrücken, wo das dann wirklich eingesetzt wird.
Hat er sie dann jetzt gefunden mittlerweile durch eigene Recherche?
Nein, ich glaube nicht. Ich habe jetzt nur den Mail-Verkehr von ihm gefordert gekriegt. Und es endete dann mit der Standardantwort.
Aber wie klein sind diese Teile denn überhaupt für die Vorstellung des normalen Menschen? Ich habe da meinetwegen meinen klassischen Aufkleber drauf, Preis und so weiter. Sehe ich dann da ganz deutlich, da ist eine Antenne eingenäht? Oder wie kann ich das überhaupt entdecken mit bloßem Auge?
Na ja, so Benetton zum Beispiel hat ja auch angekündigt, also das machen sie wohl auch, dass sie zunächst aber erstmal nur für die Lagehaltung, für ihre interne Logistik, die Dinger in Klamotten einarbeiten. Das heißt, die werden dann wahrscheinlich in einem kleinen Etikett oder Sticker drin sein. Ich weiß nicht, wäre schön, wenn da jemand mal anrufen kann, der vielleicht gerade Benetton-Klamotten gekauft hat, ob er da irgendwie was gefunden hat, was irgendwie verdächtlich aussieht. Ich selber weiß es nicht, wie die aussehen.
Du trägst einen roten Pullover.
Das ist aber auch geplant, die auf Dokumente, also wir hatten jetzt ja schon ein Beispiel bei Geldschein, die Dinger können einfach winzig klein, vor allem flach und flexibel sein. Das heißt, sie können wirklich auch als kleine Sticker auf irgendwelche Dokumente, Papiere aufgeklebt sein.
Wenn euch das Thema interessiert Berlin und Brandenburg, oder jetzt schon denkt, Moment mal, da ist doch ein dicker Haken an der Stelle, oder ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass man es besser in dem Bereich benutzt. 0331 77 97 110, meldet euch bei Fritz beim Chaosradio. Und wir hatten ja vorhin kurz nachgefragt, wer möglicherweise, ist nämlich auch eine Anwendungsmöglichkeit dieser Sache, beim Feldversuch von Ticket, von eTicket, oder hieß es Ticket oder eTicket?
Tick.et.
Tick.et, oh ja, so Wortkünstler. Also wer bei diesem Feldversuch der BVG teilgenommen hat, die das ja auch einführen möchten als Fahrscheinersatz, der hat angerufen, nämlich die Steffi. Hallo Steffi. Du hast indirekt teilgenommen, ja?
Ja, und es war, hatte eine also eine Freundin von mir, die hat da dran teilgenommen. Und ich glaube, das war auf einer U-Bahn-Linie, auf der U1 oder so. Und die hat dieses, also die hat das nicht so oft benutzt. Und dann hat sie mir das gegeben. Und ich hab das ausprobiert, aber irgendwie fand ich das nicht so begeistert. Also ich war nicht so begeistert davon.
Warum?
Weil ich das immer noch ziemlich kompliziert fand.
Aber man muss doch nur irgendwie diese Karte da jip vorbei und dann macht es dann mal biip und der ganze U-Bahnhof dreht sich um.
Dieser Bip kam halt nicht. Und dann stand ich da vor und wusste nicht wirklich, was ich tun soll.
Hast du denn die Karte auch immer jeden Monat schön brav aufgeladen?
Ich glaube, das hat sie gemacht. Also das ging ja auch um wenig so lange. Also ich hab die wirklich nur benutzt. Ich hab da... Also ich glaube, das war auch bei diesem Feldversuch musste man auch gar nichts... Also da musste man jetzt nichts aufladen oder so. Man musste halt den normalen Monatskartenbetrag zahlen oder so. Aber ich fand die Idee an sich, finde ich gut. Aber wie gesagt, mit der Umsetzung hatte das da nicht so gut geklappt.
Und hast du dir auch mal so ein Logbuch denn geholt? Es gab ja so eine Terminates dazu, wo du dir so ein Logbuch im Prinzip ausdrucken konntest, so ein Protokoll über deine Fahrten? Hast du nicht gemacht? Also hast du nicht irgendwie ein Problem damit, dass denn solche Daten auch wann wo einsteigen und wo gespeichert werden?
Das wollte ich auch gerade sagen. Also wenn das jetzt beim Einkaufen gemacht wird, dann oder ja auch beim Bus fahren oder so, dann kann ja eigentlich alles nachvollzogen werden. Also dann wird nachvollzogen, was man kauft und wo man hinfährt und also ja, da wird denke ich mal auch sehr viel Meinungsforschung drüber betrieben werden. also auch ob man jetzt mehr Markenprodukte kauft oder eher No-Name-Sachen und beim Einkaufen, ja.
Und wäre das so ein Nebeneffekt, den du quasi noch verschmerzen könntest, wenn dadurch das Einkaufen und Busfahren ganz bequem, bargeldlos, kontaktlos funktioniert?
Also, ja, ich denke schon, aber ich denke mal, die Gefahr auch bei diesem bargeldlosen Einkaufen wäre dann wie bei den Kreditkarten, also wenn man dann das irgendwie auch als Kreditkarte nutzen kann, dass man da ziemlich schnell auch Schulden macht. Also ich denke mal, das müsste dann auch so eine Beschränkung geben, wie es jetzt auch, es gibt ja auch bestimmte Girokonten, wo man halt nur Guthaben aufzahlen kann, aber keine, also man hat keinen Kredit. Ich denke mal, das müsste man da auch so machen.
Oder vielleicht noch besser, das System kennt ja dein Kaufverhalten und das warnt dich denn einfach, das brauchen sie gar nicht in den Wagen tun, das können sie sich sowieso nicht leisten.
Ja, aber ich denke mal, es birgt schon gewisse Risiken, also vor allen Dingen dieses, dass man kontrollierbar wird, total.
Und es ist auch eine Sache, die dir auf jeden Fall auch nicht behakt, oder wäre das was, wo du vielleicht auch irgendwie mit leben könntest?
Nee, nicht so wirklich. Also man will ja schon irgendwie so den Status als Individuum behalten. Und wenn man dann weiß, da könnte theoretisch so man verfolgt werden, das wäre mir nicht so angenehm.
Bist du denn mit diesem Ticket schon mal in deine Kontrolle gekommen?
Hast du das Ding noch, oder deine Freundin, oder musst du dir das wieder abgeben?
Das weiß ich nicht. Also ich hab ihr das irgendwann zurückgegeben, aber was da jetzt... Ich hatte sie irgendwann mal gefragt, ob das noch läuft, und da meinte sie mir, das wäre dann vorbei gewesen. Also irgendwie, man hat davon auch nicht mehr so wirklich was gehört, hatte ich so den Eindruck.
Also es wird jetzt gerade wieder aufgeräumt, ich weiß nicht, ob du die Medien ein bisschen verfolgt hast.
Ja, doch, auch mit der Tariferhöhung da, dass das jetzt nach Strecke abgerechnet werden soll, nicht nach Dauer, ja.
Die wollen es tatsächlich nächstes über nächstes Jahr einführen. Und, ähm, also sie haben so ein bisschen hier auch vor der Sendung mal ein bisschen, naja, gescherzt, das nicht, aber halten, haben überlegt, naja, es ist ja bei den Kontrollen, ähm, dann können ja im Prinzip die Kontrolleure, wenn die so in zivil in die U-Bahn kommen, dann gehen die halt so mit dem Gerät einfach so hintenrum bei den Leuten vorbei und gucken dann, ob die dann auch bezahlt haben und sprechen dann einfach an, so, ich weiß nicht, was wäre das irgendwie? Würde das überhaupt aus rechtlicher Sicht, aus juristischer Sicht gehen, oder könnten die das einfach machen, Nils?
Also wenn dieses Ticket, äh, dieses System so eingeführt wird, mit großem Informationszauber eben am Anfang Wir haben am Anfang und mit eingehender Erklärung des Systems und das sozusagen am Anfang ein ganz bewusster Akt, der der Nutzer stattfindet, dass sie diese Leistung so kaufen, wie sie ihnen erklärt wird. Dann wäre das sicher möglich. Man muss nachher dann im Detail gucken, ob es möglich ist, was sicherlich auch geplant ist vom Anwender, dann entsprechend die Informationen, die man erlangt, auch auszuwerten. Also tatsächlich Bewegungsprofile von einzelnen Nutzern zu erstellen und so nachvollziehen zu können, wie einer durch die Stadt gefahren ist, wann er wo war, sich wie lange aufgehalten hat an einer Bahnstation und wohin er dann wieder abgedampft ist. Also diese Erlangung von Wissen, von Informationen, die ist sehr weitgehend. Und da hätte ich auch große Schwierigkeiten, das rechtlich den Leuten klar zu machen am Anfang, was alles möglich ist mit so einem System. Da kommt man an Grenzen auch dessen, was erklärbar und rechtlich absicherungsfähig ist.
Und gerade diese Kontrollen, dass sich da die Kontrolleure praktisch heimlich von hinten anschleichen?
Also das finde ich...
Solange die dich nicht berühren.
Ja, im Grunde ist das ja eine Aushebelung. Das ist ja im Grunde die Möglichkeit, eine Durchsuchung durchzuführen, wie sie heute nur bei sehr hohen Anforderungen nach dem Recht überhaupt möglich ist. Also eine berührungslose Durchsuchung. Dafür haben wir überhaupt keine rechtlichen Legitimierungstatbestände bisher. Also da müsste sicher der Gesetzgeber für solche Geschichten auch nochmal nachlegen und solche Sachverhalte so formulieren, dass die Leute genau wissen, was auf sie zukommt. Sonst wäre das spektakulär.
Ich glaube, sie haben das auch gar nicht nötig, weil die gehen einen Schritt vorher ran. Sobald ein Mensch ohne eine Plakette, mit der er bezahlen kann, durch den Schrankenbereich tritt, geht sofort der Alarm los. Weil der hat ja nichts dabei, der ist als Körper durch einen Bewegungsdienst identifizierbar, der keine ID mit sich führt. Mit einem Fremdkörper wird dann grün angestrahlt.
Und dann kommen die Hunde.
Und mit Giftfallen.
Oder eben die Hunde. Der Klassiker. Aber das würden die auch machen, das ist ja ein Leichtes, das dann im Grunde zu bewerkstelligen. Ja Steffi, da freust du dich drauf, oder? Da gucken wir mal, ob das hier tatsächlich eingeführt wird. Vielen Dank für den Anruf, Steffi. Ihr könnt weiter anrufen, 0331 77 97 110. Wir talken gleich weiter hier im Chaosradio im Blue Moon auf Fritz. Wir haben noch gute zweieinhalb Stunden Zeit über dieses Thema zu reden. Diese Chips, die sich per Funk melden und die Welt verändern dürften, wenn das tatsächlich nicht in breitem Maße eingeführt werden sollte. Jetzt gibt es aber erst mal Nachrichten hier auf Fritz. Eine Sekunde müsste er mir noch geben, weil ich muss mal eben kurz meinen linken Fuß...
Er ist eingeschlafen, mein lieber Schollier, das geht nicht, das ist...
Fritz in Spemberg, dann nun 3, 2.
22, 30 Uhr. Fritz Info.
Mit dem Wetter, abends und nachts ziehen so ein paar Wolken durch, bei 17 bis 13 Grad. Morgen scheint erst mal die Sonne, später gibt es dann vereinzelt Schauer oder Gewitter, bei maximal 27 bis 30 Grad. Es wird schwül. Und jetzt die Meldung mit Matthias Kerkhoff.
Bei dem Stritten in der Arbeitszeit für Lehrer haben sich der Berliner Senat und die Gewerkschaften noch nicht geeinigt. Das sagte der regierende Bürgermeister Woverheit nach vierstündigen Verhandlungen. Woverheit stellte klar, dass der Senat die Erhöhung der Pflichtstundenzahl für Angestellte Lehrer nicht zurücknehmen wird. Alleinerziehende sollen künftig einen monatlichen Zuschlag von 20 Euro pro Kind bekommen. Das berichtet die Financial Times. Danach sollen Familien mit einem Jahreseinkommen von maximal 30.000 Euro diese Beihilfe bekommen. Das Lidikum Frankfurt Oder will Anzeige gegen Unbekannt erstatten. Bei dem Einbau der Wasserleitungen soll ein schwerer Fehler gemacht worden, sagte der zuständige Vorstand des Klinikträgers der Bild-Zeitung. Das Klinikum trage für die Todesfälle keine Verantwortung. In dem Krankenhaus waren zwei Menschen an der seltenen Legionärskrankheit gestorben. Unerrasch zum Sport. Fußball-Bundesligist Wolfsburg steht so gut wie sicher in einem Finale des UE-Cups. Im Halbfinale-Hinspiel siegten die Wolfsburger gegen Graz hier mit 4 zu 1. Und auf den Straßen rollt der Verkehr, wir wünschen weiter gute Fahrt.
Das Sommersafari Open Air in Sprenhagen. Zwei-Raumwohnung.
Sylvie Marx.
Tom Clark.
Miss Kitten.
Und viele mehr.
Am Samstag.
Ab 21 Uhr in Sprenhagen im Südosten Berlins.
Zwischen Adner und Fürstenwalde.
Ich höre das Chaos Radio aufs Plätzchen, ich höre mich selber aber nicht. Max von Malott, geh am Mikrofon und ich aber in diesem Fall nur Gastgeber, denn wir haben den letzten Mittwoch im Monat.
Chaos Radio ist hier am Start mit Frank und Nils vom Chaos Computer Club.
Thema heute Abend, kleine, miese, was hast du gesagt, Frank? Kleine, miese Funkfreunde, kleine, fiese Funkfreunde. Und meint eine Transponder-Karten, Funkchips, Chips, die per Funk ihre Daten übertragen. Sei es jetzt als kleine Chipkarte oder aufgeklebt auf Papier, auf Geldscheine, als elektronischen Fahrschein, wie auch immer.
Vielfältige Anwendenmöglichkeiten, Anrufer sei ich schon. Es sind viele Anrufer, 0373, 790, 110, übrigens die Nummer, wenn ihr anrufen möchtet beim Chaos Radio. Das Ganze hat natürlich ganz, ganz, ganz viele Vorteile, wie das bei solchen Systemen immer ist, wenn dann irgendjemand so was einführt. Sie brauchen sich gar nicht mehr zu bewegen, wer erfasst es, wenn sie in ihrer Wohnung tot umgefallen sind. Aber datenschutzrechtlich ergeben sich da einige, also wirklich einige Kleinigkeiten, die man beachten müsste. Und da hat Nils schon mal mehr als beide Augen geschlossen, um klarzukriegen, was es da so gibt.
Ja, was oft nicht klar kommt, dass die Leute denken, Datenschutz ist eine rein deutsche Erfindung und irgendwelche durchgeknallten Deutschen mussten das jetzt unbedingt haben, die Welt zu verrechtlichen. Das ist nicht der Fall. Also der Datenschutz kommt eigentlich aus den USA, so wie wir ihn kennen. Und wir haben das übernommen. Und es gibt eine Formel des Bundesverfassungsgerichtes aus dem Jahr 1983. Da heißt es einfach ganz knapp, jeder hat das Recht, selbst entscheiden zu können, wer was wann über ihn weiß. Und er hat das Recht, das zu wissen, was andere über ihn wissen können. Und unter dieser Formel hat dann das Gericht sozusagen Anforderungen für das Recht entworfen und hat entsprechende Gesetze verlangt, die den Leuten diese Möglichkeit geben, erkennen zu können, Transparenz haben zu können, wer was über sie weiß.
Was bei so einem System und den Möglichkeiten, die so ein System hat, nicht unbedingt an allen Ecken und Enden gegeben wäre, weswegen das Thema natürlich auch für das Chaosradio heute Abend interessant ist. Und wenn ihr euch schon so ein paar Sachen ausgemalt habt, irgendwelche Szenarien, könnt ihr jetzt anrufen. 031 70 97 110 oder wenn ihr vielleicht sogar schon mal mit dieser Technik in Berührung gekommen seid an irgendwelchen Stellen. Wir hatten als Beispiel schon den Skilift oder diesen kleinen Feldversuch der BVG, die das Ganze in den kommenden Jahren wahrscheinlich so breitflächig in Berlin einführen möchte. Am Telefon ist aber erst mal der Raul, der kennt es noch wo ganz anders.
Hallo Raul. Woher kommen bei dir die Chips?
Aus dem Schwimmbad. Und dann musst du, kaufst du irgendwie eine Monatskarte oder was machst du?
Nein, also du kommst hin, dann bezahlst du ganz normal für ein Ticket, kriegst dann so ein Schlüssel, wo oben dran halt dieser Chip dran ist und dann gehst du halt durch den Kreuz und hältst es daran und nimmst auch mit ins Wasser und so.
Was ist das für ein Schwimmbad? Ist das so ein normales Heimbad oder wo ist das oder? Okay und kannst du denn mit diesem Schlüssel dann zum Beispiel auch bezahlen, die irgendwie eine Cola kaufen oder so? So kenne ich das nämlich auch von einem Schwimmbad oder so, wo du dann im Prinzip damit bezahlen kannst. Und das ist dann der Schrankschlüssel, wo das mit dran ist oder? Okay.
Und irgendwas, was dir jetzt aufgefallen wäre, was anders ist als mit einem normalen Schlüssel oder ist es einfach nur der Plumper-Ersatz?
Obwohl eigentlich ist es nur ein Ersatz für die Karte, weil eine Karte wäre jetzt eigentlich auch jetzt aufgebracht.
Und das funktioniert so, also du gehst dann zur Kasse, wenn du reingehst, dann wird die wahrscheinlich irgendwie eingecheckt oder so, mit der Uhrzeit, wenn du reingegangen bist und du kaufst dann vermutlich ein Ticket irgendwie für, sagen wir mal, drei Stunden. Und danach, quasi, musst du halt innerhalb von drei Stunden mit dem Schlüssel dann wieder zur Kasse, oder musst du irgendwie nachbezahlen oder so, ne?
Ja, also du wirfst den dann in so ein Ding rein und der sagt dir dann, ob du die Zeit überzogen hast oder nicht.
Ja, also ich kenne das von einem Schwimmer so, dass du damit dann auch im Restaurant zum Beispiel bezahlen kannst oder am Investier dann halt da irgendwie Kohle oder Pommes oder so holen kannst. Und du brauchst nicht die ganze Zeit das Geld mit dir rum schleppen, sondern du bezahlst dann zum Schluss an der Kasse auch alles das, was du verzehrt hast. Das ist natürlich ein Problem, wenn du das Ding verlierst quasi, dann kann da jeder auf deine Kosten mit dann einen schönen Tag machen. Und du gehst dann zur Kasse und musst dann da vielleicht 120 Euro bezahlen, weil das jemand richtig doll ausgekostet hat und seine ganzen Freunde auch noch eingeladen hat. Also klar, wenn es in dem Schwimmbad da so die Möglichkeiten gibt, kann es gut sein. Muss man mal probieren oder kannst du ja mal fragen, ob du damit denn noch irgendwelche Zusatzleistungen oder so in Anspruch nehmen kannst. Aber die wird dann danach dann auch wieder eingesammelt. Den kannst du nicht mitnehmen, sondern ist es dann da am Schlüssel dran.
Paul, danke für den Anruf. Und am Telefon ist der Sascha aus Hessen ruf an. Hallo Sascha.
Ich wollte euch mal so den richtigen Kurs so, da denke ich halt gibt es so ein paar ganz spezielle Sachen, gerade wenn man so in Kaufhäusern ist oder so, ja. Ich meine, die Leute können doch dann gerade effizienter auch das Kaufverhalten studieren durch diese Chips, weil sie irgendwo genau wissen, was hat der Mensch gekauft, auch bei diesen Kundenkarten, die es ja schon fast überall irgendwo gibt. Also ich meine, wie gesagt, dadurch steht ja auch irgendwo eine Gefahr. Ich denke da so an Karstadt, ich meine, ich bin so auf der ländlichen Gegend, da wird das so schnell nicht kommen oder so, ja. Aber wie gesagt, wenn man so der Gegend hier ist, so in den größeren Städten, da gibt es ja wie gesagt bei Karstadt immer Kundenkarten und keine Ahnung, ja. Da muss man ja auch seine Daten hinterlassen. Irgendwo kommt dann auch irgendwann, denke ich, wieder so eine Massenverhabeflut durch diese Karten, diese Empfänger und so.
Aber im Prinzip ist doch eigentlich nichts anderes als jetzt der Barcode auch.
Ja gut, ich bin selbst ein bisschen Programmierer. Ich mache ja momentan auch mit Barcodes eine Warenwirtschaft. Der Barcode, da ist ja letzten Endes doch eigentlich nur so, dass das Ding meistens zu identifizieren genommen wird eines Artikels oder so. Ich meine, da habe ich wirklich noch den Vorteil, dass ich halt irgendwo sagen kann, ich identifiziere einen Artikel und über den Benutzer selbst, denn irgendwo kein Daten gespeichert. Aber wenn so Kundenkarten erstellt werden, dann ist das doch irgendwo viel einfacher.
Aber jetzt der Unterschied zwischen einem Barcode und diesen RFIDs, also um da jetzt nochmal zurückzukommen. Also bisher haben wir es ja auch schon, wenn wir jetzt zum Beispiel so ein Payback-System oder so ein Rabatt-System haben. Da gehe ich dann mit meinen Artikeln zur Kasse, die werden über den Scanner gezogen. Und dann habe ich auf dem Bong auch drauf irgendwie dreimal Rotwein, Pampers, dies und jenes Chips.
Rotweinpampers gibt es auch schon.
Rotweinpampers, genau, die Ersatzflüssigkeit. Lecker. Dass du das dann mit deiner Rabattkarte verknüpft wird und daraus in so ein Profil erstellt wird. Also eigentlich braucht es dafür keinen RFID, keine Funk-Tags, oder?
Ja gut, eigentlich theoretisch gesehen nicht. Aber es ist so, dass man diesen RFIDs, doch die Gefahr viel höher ist, denke ich, irgendwo. Weil man kriegt das Dinge dann wirklich an jeder Ecke zugejubelt. Und es wird definitiv, wie gesagt, kommen. Dann ist ja auch, wie gesagt, die Gefahr, dass das Kundenverhalten studiert wird. Also auch nicht nur, wenn man sich registriert. Das Kundenverhalten wird intensiv eigentlich viel mehr irgendwo zusammengesucht. Man weiß halt genau, die Kunden kaufen vielleicht zuerst auf der ersten Etage ein. Dann wird halt auf der ersten Etage mehr das positioniert, worauf die Leute halt Lust haben, was sie kaufen wollen.
Zum Teil wissen die solche Sachen natürlich schon. Die wissen, wo sie viel verkaufen, wo sie wenig verkaufen. Und unten an der Kasse sind die Schreisüßigkeiten für die Kinder positioniert, damit der 75 Zentimeter große Kleinkind-Kopf dann auch sofort sieht, ah, hier ist Snickers wunderbar. Aber ich meine, was ich interessant finde an der Sache ist, wenn du irgendwo anders vorbeigehst und du hast 1000 Karten in der Tasche, wo die eben funken, dann wissen die, dass du auch eben eine Kundenkarte bei Chaosrad hast. Die können ja diese Verbindungen untereinander von diesen Firmen, die sind natürlich relevant.
Ja genau, das ist ja auch so ein Thema. Wie gesagt, das wird ja alles gespeichert letzten Endes. Wenn man wirklich so eine Karte hat, klar, Chaosrad und was weiß ich, hängt sich noch alles zusammen da an der ganzen Ecke. Wie gesagt, ich denke, es ist irgendwo gesteht durch ein Informat, dass die Leute wirklich wissen, was man wirklich will und man kann dadurch die Kaufsuche des Menschen irgendwie steuern.
Vor allen Dingen diese Nummer. Ich hätte ja tatsächlich Kumpels, die Suchmaschinen benutzt haben, sowas wie Alta Vista, und die sind ja oben Werbebanner gesteuert, dadurch, was für einen Suchbegriff eingegeben wurde. Das kennt man jetzt nicht mehr so, weil alle benutzen Google. Früher war das noch ein bisschen so. Und da hatte ich so einen Kumpel, der meinte tatsächlich so, ey, die sind so, ich war da, hab da was gesucht, und jetzt stell dir vor, da oben drüber, da war so ein großer Button, da stand genau das drauf, was ich gesucht habe. Und diesen Effekt, den checken die Leute nicht, selbst wenn du das mit dem Hammer drauf haust, und ich glaube, dass sowas wie ID-gesteuerte Werbung dann auch kommen wird, dass du irgendwo vorbeiläufst, die sehen, ah, okay, der kauft auch hier oft Socken, also zack, die neue Sockenwerbung an die Wand. So, auf so einem großen Screen oder sowas. Mister Yukunishi, oder wie gesagt.
Das ist übrigens auch gar keine Vision, dass es mal so kommt, sondern es gibt tatsächlich den Future Store, heißt er, ich glaube, in Duisburg hat er aufgemacht. Und das ist so eine Zukunftsvision eigentlich, also das ist kein, sagen wir, kein serienreifer Supermarkt, sondern eher so eine Art Prototyp, zumindest dieses ganze System, die ganze Elektronik, die da drinnen ist. Wo du dann im Prinzip auch so einen kleinen Tablett-PC oder so was an deinem Einkaufswagen hast, an deinem Trolley.
Ich hab den Bericht schon drüber gesehen. War relativ interessant, also wie gesagt, dass man dann den alten Oma's dann auch erklärt, wofür das neue Produkt da ist und so.
Das war schon ganz lustig.
Echt ist das so, dass die dann auch direkt da geflutet werden mit Informationen?
Ja, dementsprechend, wo man gerade steht, so wie ich das in dem Bericht verstanden hab, ja, genau die Informationen zum Produkt abrufen und so weiter, dass man genau sehen kann, ja, Preis, Füllgewicht und den ganzen Käsehalter rundrum.
Aber du kennst dich damit ja offensichtlich auch aus, sagst aber, du bist bei dieser Barcode-Industrie auch involviert. Bist du dann bald arbeitslos oder?
Nein, nein, ich bin auch auf Herstellensuche und mache mir hinterm Praktikum bei einer Firma. Ah, okay.
Ich dachte schon, ich schlagen doch alle drei Kreuze und sage, oh man, das wird übel.
Ja, wie gesagt, ich denke, da sind irgendwo schon Gefahren versteckt, die man irgendwann nicht unterschätzen sollte. Wie gesagt, Massenwerbung kennen wir ja zu Gute.
Also ich denke auch, Sascha hat da in diesem Bereich, was die private Wirtschaft angeht, den entscheidenden Punkt eigentlich aus meiner Sicht auch gesagt. Da geht es um Kundenprofile. Das ist letztlich auch das entscheidende Ziel der Industrie hier. Und das schafft Manipulationsmöglichkeiten, die tendenziell eben auch in Widerspruch geraten können zu dem Menschenbild, was wir von unseren Gesetzen her und von unserer Verfassung her geschaffen haben. Wir wollen ja eigentlich den selbstbestimmten Menschen, der eben auch ganz bewusst sich für das eine oder das andere entscheiden kann, auswählen kann und wenn das quasi hintenrum läuft, ohne sein Wissen eigentlich mehr oder weniger passiv an ihm vorbeiläuft, er in Sachen reingetrieben wird, dann entspricht das im Grunde nicht mehr diesem Menschenbild unserer Gesetze. Und da ist der Widerspruch da, der eben zum Beispiel in der Datenschutzdiskussion dann thematisiert wird.
Ja, Sascha, wir sind alle total down jetzt.
Jungs, kann ich euch mal kurz was sagen?
Und zwar würde ich gerne einen großen Open Source-Projekt loslassen, wenn es möglich ist, weil ich da Projektleiter bin.
Ja, mach mal, dann habe ich nämlich gleich einen Link noch zu was anderes.
Alles klar, vielen Dank. Dann würde ich gerne die Entwickler vom Secoto-Projekt grüßen.
Wie ist geschehen?
Genau, dann würde ich nämlich gleich noch erwähnen, dass Debian die nächsten Tage, ungefähr in zwei Wochen Geburtstag feiert, nämlich im 10. Geburtstag. Debian ist eine große Linux-Distribution, sowas wie SUSE oder Red Hat, nur eben ganz frei und unkommerziell.
Und, sind wir eingeladen?
Ja, am 16. und 17. August in www.infodrome.org.debian.party findet ihr dazu was. Das wurde ich gebeten auch zu erwähnen. Und Debian ist eigentlich eine gute Sache, weil es ist eine freie Linux-Distribution, komplett unkommerziell und aber trotzdem auch professionell einsetzbar. Und da gehen schon mal so weit erstmal Glückwünsche an 10 Jahre erfolgreich bestanden.
Ok, Sascha, vielen Dank für den Anruf. So, ihr könnt natürlich mithocken, 073797110. Ihr seht schon, das Thema ist nicht gerade uninteressant. Wenn auch die Abkürzung RFID nicht so super sexy daherkommt, da versteckt sich viel dahinter und zeigt auch mal die eine oder andere Brust. Christian ist am Telefon. Hallo Christian.
Hallo Christian.
Also mein Problem ist eigentlich, wie soll ich das jetzt sagen, dass wenn man nicht weiß, wo die Dinger draufkleben, wie das jetzt am Anfang dieses Beispiel war, wo man sich dann auch erkundigen will und die das nicht sagen wollen, beziehungsweise halt auch bei CNA, wenn die das halt wirklich in die Sachen einkleben oder einnähen und man das gar nicht rauslösen kann. Sprich, wenn man dann irgendwo rumläuft und die ja praktisch abchecken kann, wo kann man einkaufen oder wo war man einkaufen? Und dass man die dann halt nicht ablösen kann. Es gibt ja jetzt auch diese Dinger halt, dass man die Klamotten nicht aus dem Laden raustragen kann. Und die werden ja vorher abgemacht.
Das sind diese Diebstahlsicherungen. Also eigentlich ist ja diese Technologie selbst schon relativ alt. Hier gibt es ja auch schon eine ganze Weile diese elektronischen Waren-Sicherungen, die dann irgendwie ganz laut tröten, wenn man sich irgendwie da was mit das T-Shirt gesteckt hat. Das ist praktisch der quasi der analoge Vorgänger davon. Da wird ja nichts identifiziert, sondern da gibt es im Prinzip nur so, da ist was. Und von einem anderen Laden passt es dann meist auch schon nicht mehr oder so. Die werden dann entweder deaktiviert mit so einem Magneten oder so funktioniert. Die werden dann glaube ich durchgebrannt irgendwie schnell diese Spulen oder irgendwie herausgelöst an so einem Etikett. Das ist halt noch eine andere Klasse, wo ich noch sagen kann, naja gut, wenn die Läden da haben halt Probleme, wird viel geklaut und so was. Da wirst du ja auch nicht identifiziert oder so. Also was halt passiert, dass es dann die Kamera angeht auch. Nur wirklich dann, wenn tatsächlich auch was geklaut wird in dem Moment. Nicht jetzt wie bei diesem Rasierklinge-Beispiel, wo es dann irgendwann mal präventiv, ja der nimmt jetzt eine Rasierklinge, der wird die sowieso klauen, so das wissen wir jetzt schon. Deswegen filmen wir den mal sicherheitshalber.
Was ich halt meine ist, dass die Dinge halt nicht deaktiviert werden voraussichtlich und man die die ganze Zeit mit sich rumträgt. Halt auch außerhalb des Ladens. Und man selber halt nicht an die Information rankommt, was die Dinge funken. Aber andere dafür. Wo ich das schon gekauft habe und das eigentlich jetzt erledigt sein könnte.
Das heißt, du kannst dann bei dem nächsten Einkauf in einem Klamottenladen schon als guter Kunde, als Stammkunde schon beim Reingehen erkannt werden. Du wirst dann gleich freundlich begrüßt, also in ganz Nähe zu dir. Und wissen ja eigentlich auch schon, was du haben willst.
Ja, das ist halt auch so ein Ding wäre, wenn ich halt eine Autoversicherung habe, kriege ich dann halt irgendeine Karte, wo so ein Ding draufklebt und mich dann halt irgendjemand anspricht, ob ich nicht die Autoversicherung wechseln will, weil ihre wäre ja viel billiger oder so. Der kann mir das dann gleich ausrechnen, was ich da für eine Klasse bin oder keine Ahnung und macht mir dann gleich das super Angebot. Und ja, das finde ich dann halt auch nicht so in Ordnung.
Genau, und dass Sie Krebs haben, tut uns leid. Oh, das wussten Sie nicht. Oh, dann entschuldige ich mich. Dann erfahren Sie das morgen von Ihrem Arzt. Der hat es Ihnen aber schon auf Ihrer Kundenkarte geschrieben.
Genau, also dass es praktisch die ganzen Privatsphäreflüge gibt. Also dass man als Kunde nicht mehr selber entscheiden kann, welche Informationen trage ich jetzt nach außen. Wenn man die dann selber deaktivieren könnte, was sich durch Magneten oder wie auch immer, dann wäre das ja noch in Ordnung. Also dann könnte ich damit leben, weil zur Zeit gibt es ja auch diese Kundenkarten, die schon erwähnt wurden, wie Payback oder so. Und da macht man es ja bewusst.
Genau, also der Parallelfall, den wir jetzt diskutieren, zum Beispiel in der Datenschutzdiskussion bei der Biometrie, ist die Frage, ob wir jetzt bei der Erfassung von biometrischen Daten ein Verfahren nehmen, bei dem du aktiv, sozusagen ganz bewusst deinen Fingerabdruck hergibst und dann weißt du auch, dass du das getan hast. Oder wir ein Verfahren einführen, bei dem dir es passieren kann, dass ohne dein Wissen deine Daten erhoben werden, zum Beispiel ein Gesichtscan durch eine Kamera, die irgendwo hängt, die du nicht gesehen hast und die eben die Möglichkeit hat, möglicherweise dich automatisch zu erfassen, ohne dass dir diese Geschichte bewusst ist. Und das ist das, was Christian eigentlich anspricht, die Unsicherheit, ob da jetzt in irgendeiner Form Daten erhoben worden sind oder nicht. Genau schon diese Unsicherheit allein ist das rechtliche Problem. Das ist ganz interessant, genau das hat das Verfassungsgericht gesagt. Wer diese Unsicherheit verspürt, der kann in der Folge irgendwie gehindert sein, seine Rechte so wahrzunehmen, wie er das möchte. Also der wird irgendwie unsicher und dadurch nicht mehr so frei, wie ihn eben das Gericht als guten Staatsbürger sich wünscht.
Ich kann halt auch nicht dagegen angehen. Also ich kann niemanden verklagen, wenn ich nicht weiß, wer jetzt meine Daten hat.
Ja, also auch dieser Auskunftsanspruch, das ist auch ein ganz großes Problem. Letztlich dann überhaupt zu wissen, bei wem erkundige ich mich, als ob diese RF-Tags überhaupt eingesetzt worden sind und wie funktionieren die genau. Also du wirst immer mit deinem Auskunftsanspruch wahrscheinlich zu kurz greifen. Du kommst nicht an alle Informationen ran, die du brauchst. Und das wird ein weiteres Problem sein, was uns beschäftigen wird.
Also du weißt, also um das mal zu verbetlichen, wenn du jetzt so ein Ding im Supermarkt gekauft hast, dann kannst du davon ausgehen, dass der Supermarkt die Sachen möglicherweise gespeichert hat, die Daten. Du kannst aber auch nicht sicher sein, dass du nicht z.B. die Spedition unterwegs auch die Sachen gespeichert hast. Und die Spedition weiß ja dann auch schon, dass du es dann später gekauft hast. Also sie haben zumindest die Information, welcher Artikel an welchen Kunden gegangen ist. Oder den hat denn der Supermarkt. Aber da sind halt irgendwie spannende Konstellationen möglich.
Und der Christoph aus Berlin ist am Telefon. Hallo Christoph. Christoph, bist du noch da?
Christoph.
Moment, wir müssen mal auf der Seite. Christoph? Nee. Christoph kotzt es aber an. So viel konnte man hier zumindest noch lesen. Okay Christoph, wir registrieren das. Dann wäre als nächstes dran, wir machen das hier schön in der richtigen Reihenfolge. Oh, interessant. Der Johann hatte schon mal Chipkontakt. Hallo Johann.
Ja hallo.
Hallo Johann.
Was war denn das für ein Chip?
Das war so ein kleiner schwarzer Runder. So ganz klein und ganz dünn. Also so hauchdünn, man konnte ihn da nicht durchbrechen.
Lass mich raten, das hat was zu tun mit Jogging oder einer Sportveranstaltung? Ah ok, also auch an so einem Skilift.
Und da war halt so eine Schranke. So die ging hoch, wenn das Gerät den Schub abfasst hatte. Und mein Freund fuhr da halt links. Die Schranke lag genau in Fahrtrichtung, man konnte eigentlich direkt durchfahren, man musste ein bisschen einsteigen und dann hat man voll Krache und die Schranke ging halt nicht hoch.
Und er ist voll reingefahren.
Das heißt, er hat sich darauf verlassen, dass die dann eigentlich hoch geht.
Genau.
Interessante Schadensersatzfrage.
Wahrscheinlich stand da aber im Kleingedruckten, wenn du das mit diesem, du hast dann so einen Vertrag unterschrieben, wenn du den Chip nimmst, da steht dann so für den Fall, dass die Schranke mal nicht hoch geht, ist das nicht unsere Schuld.
Oder nur 10 kmh fahren.
Und wie war das bei dir? Konnte man damit dann auch noch woanders bezahlen? Oder war das auch wieder nur für diese Schranke?
Nee, man konnte da auf der Piste, da waren halt noch so Läden, da konnte man alles halt bezahlen.
Echt, mit diesem Chip denn?
Ja, das Problem war halt dann nur, dass du nicht wusstest, wie viel du bezahlst, so richtig. Dann hat er einfach irgendwie einen Chip hingehalten, okay, gut, Geld weg.
Wie war das denn? Das war so ein Prepaid, also du musstest denn vorher da was aufladen oder wurde das später abgebucht und nachhinein?
Nein, man hat das Hotel gesagt, wo man wohnte, und die haben es alles ins Hotel geschickt und auf die Rechnung gesetzt.
Oh, das ist aber echt heikel. Und hattest du eine Möglichkeit zu sehen, was schon auf deinem Chip alles so abgegessen wurde, also dass du wusstest, okay, ich habe mir jetzt schon meine Badehose gekauft, obwohl ich die im Skiurlaub nicht brauche und so?
Ja, man konnte beim Hotel nachfragen, wie viel ich da jetzt schon ausgegeben hatte.
Aber war Mühe, ja, also man konnte nicht einfach so an so einem Ding vorbeigehen und gucken, was habe ich schon bezahlt?
Konnten die bei dem Hotel auch sehen, was du gekauft hast?
Und wie lief das also? Weil ich würde mir von so einem Ding ja wünschen, das würde ich mir auch, wenn ich irgendwas kaufe, wünschen, nach dem Motto, ich gehe mit meiner Karte da vorbei, dann sagt er, Ihre Karte wurde erfasst. Wenn Sie jetzt bezahlen möchten, dann drücken Sie bitte hier und bestätigen Sie mit Ihrem Code oder so einem Kram. Die haben aber offensichtlich nicht irgendwelche Bestätigungen verlangt. Du hast nur dein Ding gegeben und durch.
Ja genau, das war also zum Beispiel, ja genau. Und wenn man im Restaurant war, dann hat der Oberlehrer einfach den Chip genommen, dann so ein Gerät gehalten und zurückgegeben.
Und war die Rechnung am Ende okay oder?
Ja, meine Eltern haben es ja bezahlt.
Wie ist denn das denn eigentlich? Ist das Kaufen? Also ich meine, ist man ja noch nicht voll geschäftsfähig irgendwie. Kann das dann auch zu Problemen führen für die Händler möglicherweise auch? Wahrscheinlich analog wie beim normalen...
Ja, das geht nach dem normalen bürgerlichen Gesetzbuch. Und da ist dann immer die Frage, ob entsprechend eben jemand hinreichend eben geschäftsfähig ist, um solche Geschäfte zu tätigen. Ansonsten hat das Problem meistens dann der Händler, weil er nicht sicher sein kann, dass sein Vertrag wirksam zustande gekommen ist. Also deshalb müsste der eigentlich ein Interesse daran haben, ein Backup durch die Eltern zu haben, eine Unterschrift von den Eltern, dass das entsprechend alles rechtlich wasserdicht ist.
Und wofür muss man geschäftsfähig sein, also für was für Aktionen?
Na ja, also um nochmal diesen Vertrag abzuschließen, um entsprechend einkaufen zu können, eben diese Geschäfte im Cola-Kauf tätigen zu können, da muss eben sichergestellt sein, dass das jetzt kein Minderjähriger ist, der bei dem man, obwohl das wieder eine Ausnahme ist, also das sind diese Alltagsgeschäfte, die man auch als Minderjähriger natürlich tätigen kann.
Johann, du bist 13, haben die irgendwo gemuckt?
Ja, also nein, nicht bei mir, aber...
So als ich mir das Snowboard für 500 Euro kaufen wollte.
Ja, zum Beispiel, aber andere haben es auch gesehen, wenn sie sehr, sehr tore Sachen gekauft haben und die halt noch etwas jünger waren.
Und mit diesem, der Bezahlvorgang, der war aber schon so, dass du diesen Chip dann irgendwo hinhalten musstest? Oder reicht das, wenn du da so neben der Kasse stehren müsst?
Ja, man musste den abgeben meistens. Man hat gar nicht wirklich mitbekommen, wie ich jetzt gemacht habe.
Sehr geheimnisvoll. Man musste sich am Verkäufer reiben. Okay, Johann, vielen Dank für den Anruf. Und bevor wir zum nächsten kommen, eine kurze Verwirrung.
Hallo, hier sind die Sportfreunde Stiller.
Hi, ich bin die Nina aus dem Heavy-Hellas-Dorf.
Und ihr hört immer noch das Chaosradio auf. Fritz, der Michael aus Falkensee ist. Am Telefon. Hallo, Michael.
Also, ich hab einen Studentenausweis, ne? Und früher war das bei uns so, um in die Ateliers reinzukommen. Da musste man, also wie üblich, da diesen Ausweis in so einen Schlitz rein. Und dann ging halt die Atelier-Tür auf. Und jetzt haben sie es eben auch umgestellt auf dieses neue System. Also einfach nur gerade ranhalten. Und da hab ich mal eine Frage. Ich hab neulich so eine Nivea Visage Cremendose gekauft. Die war ja noch in so einer Pappverpackung. Und auf der Tube war hinten praktisch so ein Barcode-Aufkleber drauf. Den hab ich abgemacht. Und da war hinten auch so ein elektronischer Spion drauf. Irgendwie so ein Plasteding mit so einem Metallstreifen eingewäbt.
Diese Metallstreifen sind meistens diese normalen Warnsicherungen. Also für diese Alarm-Lagermausgänge.
Das ist nicht das Gleiche.
Na ja, ist natürlich dem Ding schwer anzusehen.
Weil ich nämlich mal so eine Geschichte gehört habe von so einem Ladendieb. Der hat Aluminiumfolie gekauft und eine Packung Waschpulver. Also dann hat er das an der Kasse bezahlt, ist sozusagen rausgegangen, hat das Waschpulver ausgekippt und hat diesen Karton innen drin mit dieser Aluminiumfolie ausgekleidet. Ist wieder rein und hat sich dann praktisch den Karton vollgepackt. Und wurde dann ausmarschiert. Und wurde praktisch nur von dem Agenten, also nee, wie heißt das hier?
Vom Ladendetektiv.
Von dem Ladendetektiv wurde festgenommen, weil er das irgendwie mitgekriegt hat, dass er irgendwie das Waschpulver weggeschmissen hat. Deswegen muss ich mal fragen, ob man diese Schutzsicherung auch irgendwie abstimmen kann. Also quasi, was weiß ich, mit Aluminiumfolie oder...
Na, wir telefonieren danach her, oder gleich nochmal auch mit jemanden, der sich da schon ein bisschen mit beschäftigt hat und der wird uns das wahrscheinlich auch beantworten können.
Das wissen wir schon so genau, weil wir das Gespräch natürlich schon aufgezeichnet haben. Wir wollen auch nicht lügen hier. Und da wird genau diese Frage beantwortet werden. Also, sozusagen, du darfst gespannt sein, in etwa 5 bis 10 Minuten kommt die Auflösung. Aber allem wird natürlich vorangestellt beim Chaosradio, dass wir natürlich nicht ermutigen, das zu tun, sondern dass wir nur sagen, wie es geht. Ja, für die Hochschule, damit du dann da ins Atelier reinkommst. Du komplett eingepackt in Alufolie.
Wobei, ich meine, das ist jetzt gar nicht mal so abwegig. Also es geht jetzt gar nicht um diese Diebstahl-Sicherung bei uns in der Sendung. Das ist ja schon irgendwie zehn Jahre alte Technologie, sondern wir wollen uns ja vor allem über diese Identifikationstags unterhalten. Und wenn ich jetzt so einen praktischen, ja, einen Einkauf unter Wahrung meiner Privatsphäre tätigen will, darf ich mir denn da eigentlich auch selbst helfen? Nils, wie sieht das aus? Könnte ich denn anfangen, da Sachen irgendwie abzukleben, abzudecken oder so? Wenn ich jetzt Angst habe, dass ich da im Supermarkt vollends beobachtet werde?
Sozusagen als Selbsthilfe oder als Selbstschutzmaßnahme, weil ich da nicht gescannt werde.
Oder zum Beispiel dann auch die Banknoten, Geldnoten, die sowas haben, oder irgendwelche Artikel, mein neues Benetton-T-Shirt, dann irgendwie kurz in die Mikrowelle packe oder so, dass die Dinger durchbrezeln?
Also, wenn ich das Ding gekauft habe und schon mit nach Hause geschleppt habe und dann sicher gehen will, dass das Ding nicht abstrahlt und irgendwie, wenn ich durch die Straße renne, da Informationen abgibt von mir, dass da kann ich natürlich den vorher in die Mikrowelle legen, wenn es da den Pullover nicht verbritzelt. Das ist mein gutes Recht bei meinem Eigentum. Es wird wahrscheinlich ein Problem, wenn ich anfange im Supermarkt da irgendwelche größeren Aktionen vorzunehmen, weil das möglicherweise dann da zu dem Zeitpunkt schon eine Sachbeschädigung sein könnte, weil die Sache eben immer noch jemand anderem gehört und der eben solche Substanzbeeinträchtigungen natürlich nicht möchte und auch ein Recht darauf hat.
Aber Einwickeln in Alufolie wäre okay?
Also da könnte ich mir vorstellen, dass es hier zumindest ein Grenzfall ist.
Das kann man leider wieder auspacken, oder? Was haben Sie denn da drin? Gut, dann vielen Dank an dich auch.
Aber ganz kurz eine Frage noch, welcher Uni ist es, wenn ich fragen darf? Und wird das denn auch für andere Sachen eingesetzt, oder ist das nur für die Zutrittskontrolle?
Glaube ich, ja, genau.
Also noch nicht irgendwie in der Mensa?
Ich glaube, die Karte kann man noch irgendwie aufladen oder so.
Dann kann man damit bezahlen.
Und weißt du zufällig auch, welche Daten denn da gespeichert werden, oder wie das verarbeitet wird?
Also ich schätze mal, der Wachschutz, das Cat wird um 10 Uhr zugemacht. Und in die Ateliers kann man praktisch rund um die Uhr rein, wenn man da abends arbeiten will. Das sind Architekten, Produktdesigner, Grafikdesigner und so. Und die sind halt nachtaktiv mehr. Also klar, wenn man da irgendwie reingeht, dann ist wahrscheinlich schon das Semester, und der Name und alles so registriert. Falls da irgendwie was passiert, Brandstiftung oder was weiß ich irgendwie, wenn da irgendwas geklaut wird oder so, dann wissen die auf jeden Fall, welche Leute zu der und der Zeit eben raus und rein sind. Also raus nicht, aber auf jeden Fall rein.
Hast du mal versucht dich zu erkundigen, wie lange diese Daten denn aufbewahrt werden?
Nee, keine Ahnung.
Mach das mal.
Der Rat von Frank mit einer zuckenden Augenbraube. Michael, vielen Dank für den Anruf. Ihr hört wie jeden letzten Mittwoch im Monat das Chaos Radio auf Fritz. Bestandteile des Chaos Radios sind immer Mitglieder des Chaos Computer Clubs. Am heutigen Abend der Frank und der Nils. Meine Person Max von Malotky von Fritz beigestellt, um sozusagen helfend auf der anderen oder der einen Seite da zu stehen und natürlich euch zu begrüßen am Telefon. Das kann nur ich. Ihr könnt anrufen zum Thema heute Abend. Ein wirklich interessantes Thema und zwar so kleine Dinge, die im Grunde die Barcodes ersetzen sollen. Auf dem, was ihr momentan kauft, die sind ja fast überall drauf. Auf jedem Ding, wo irgendwas bezahlt wird oder auf Artikeln sind die ja meistens schon draufgedruckt. Bei zum Beispiel finde ich ja geil bei Aldi. Haben sie es ja so geschickt, jetzt verbessert, dass die quasi umlaufend um die ganzen Produkte einen Barcode Ring haben, sodass du auch gar keine Chance hast, eine Seite zu erwischen, wo kein Barcode ist. Das System wird einfach abgelöst werden durch ein anderes, nämlich durch das Überdaseurdaten sprechen, dass diese Teile einfach nur irgendwo in die Nähe gehalten werden müssen mit so kleinen Funkchips drauf. Und dann hat sich das schon, dann weiß jeder, was ihr eingekauft habt. Am Telefon ist der Stefan. Hallo Stefan.
Ja hallo, wundervollen, schönen Abend und alles. Ja, gut, also ich bin in der Branche. Überwachung, Warnsicherung, Quellensicherung ist da wahrscheinlich mehr der Zauberwort, weil die größten Firmen, ob es die großen Kaufhausketten KTW, K-Stadt, Fertiwertheim ganz besonders eigentlich sind, die arbeiten in der Art und Weise heutzutage schon mit den Herstellern von zum Beispiel gerade namenshaften Klamottenunternehmen zusammen. Dass dort diese Chips, und die sind jetzt schon seit langem eigentlich dabei, in die Sachen eingenäht werden. Vorhin wurde angesprochen, Warnsicherung, analoge Technik, Magnetechnik. Also unsere Firma hat diese Sache schon lange abgeschoben und wir bauen inzwischen Systeme, die direkt als Quellensicherung mit den Herstellern von Produkten, Artikeln zusammenarbeiten. Und dort diese Chips, diese RFID-Technik, eigentlich dann doch schon in den Produkten mit eingenäht ist. Und so eigentlich besser, sag ich mal, doch der Ladendieb erfasst werden kann. Beziehungsweise das geht dann hinaus bis zur Kontrolle in Firmen, wo dann Zutrittssysteme gleichzeitig mit der Videoanlage gekoppelt sind, dass man eigentlich muss mal auswählen, welcher Mitarbeiter befindet sich wo so in der Art. Also die sind da doch eigentlich schon alle weit. Also weil ich jetzt immer höre, das kommt, jetzt ist es schon da. Also es wird in der Art und Weise doch schon praktiziert. Gerade die größten, die jetzt entsprechend das Monopol haben, das Geld haben, die erlauben sich dann auch diese Technik.
Ja und wie ist denn das denn in so einem Geschäft? Da ist jetzt dieser Tag in meinem T-Shirt, sag ich mal, eingenäht und dann gehe ich damit zur Kasse, dann wird das Ding erfasst, ich bezahle und da wird dann wahrscheinlich intern in einer Datenbank quasi freigeschaltet zum Ausgang.
Das Ding wird dann deaktiviert. Ich sag mal, in welchem Rahmen, weil ich bin jetzt nicht der Techniker, ich bin eher Marketing tätig und in welchem Rahmen das dann wirklich deaktiviert wird und wie es weiterverwendbar ist, kann ich jetzt nicht sagen. Da kann man natürlich paranoide Fantasien ausmalen. Aber ich sag mal so, das geht dann alles nur noch über den Computer. Der Artikel wird eingelesen. Und das ist dann wohl mit dem Barcode auch zusammengehangen. Und wenn nicht, dann ist da irgendwo ein Leser an der Kasse. Also Quellensicherung an sich ist jetzt schon seit Jahren vorhanden. Ich sag mal, die namentlichen Hersteller von Klamotten, so das sind hier Hugo Boz und diese ganzen Edelanzüge, die machen das schon seit einer Raumzeit.
Möhen ganz kurz, was heißt Quellensicherung genau?
Quellensicherung ist, dass der Artikel, das Produkt vom Hersteller direkt mit dem Chip versehen wird. Dass der eigentlich mit dem, also ich sag mal, es gibt dort eine Firma, die Namen möchte ich jetzt nicht nennen, die das eigentlich mehr oder weniger erfunden hat, wird, wenn man ein bisschen im Internet surft, man das auch rausfinden. 60 Prozent des Marktes in der Waren-Sicherung hat, dort diese Technologie eingeführt, mit dieser RF-ID, ist das von RF-Technologie eingeführt wurde, dass dort direkt Verhandlungen, Rahmenverträge geschlossen sind. Also die stehen zum größten Teil, wie gesagt, mit den größten, mit den reichsten KDW, Herthy, Wertheim, zum Beispiel Karstadt, dass die direkt mit dem System zusammenarbeiten und die Hersteller diese Chips direkt in die Produkte mit einnehmen.
Sind das jetzt Phillips oder Motorola oder Texas Instruments als Hersteller von diesen Chips? Oder sind das jetzt Firmen, die speziell Lösungen anbieten dafür?
Das ist eine Firma, die sich darauf spezialisiert hat. Damit ist eine amerikanische Firma den Markt eigentlich schon mehr oder weniger komplett abgedeckt hat. Also es ist an sich eine Technik, die jetzt schon seit Jahren funktioniert. Und gerade die, die das entsprechende Geld haben, die bauen diese analogen Systeme, die man, sag ich mal, wie mit so ein bisschen... Also die Dinge auszutricksen, die sich maschen. Also die Ene wurde schon angesprochen, hier mit ein bisschen Alufolie um den Dongel rum. Und die Sache hat sich erledigt. Die wird ausgetauscht heutzutage, gerade von den ersten großen Kaufhäusern, das ist schon längst geschehen, gegen diese RFID-Technik, die als Quellensicherung in den Produkten drin ist.
Also mich würde jetzt schon nochmal interessieren, wie die jetzt genau deaktiviert werden. Also ob jetzt praktisch dieser Chip dann an der Kasse quasi unbrauchbar gemacht wird, zerstört wird und dadurch nicht mehr aktiv wird, oder ob die ID, die auf dem Chip drauf ist, dann quasi freigeschaltet wird für diese Ausgangsbaken, also für diese Schleuse pro Stamm Ausgang.
Ja, mir wurde mal gesagt, der Chip wird komplett zerstört, also ist gut. Wie weit das dann wirklich passiert, kann man ja im Endeffekt auch nicht wissen. Ich will jetzt hier nicht irgendwelche Paraniden-Höngeschwindigste an der Wand malen.
Vielleicht kannst du dich da einfach mal erkundigen und eine Mail schreiben an 84.chaosradio.ccc.de, weil das ist ja schon was, was auch interessant ist dann, ob die danach dann noch irgendwie brauchbar sind, auch so als Sicht der Kunden, des Kundenschutzes, oder ob die dann, also wie das da vor sich geht, oder ob die denn da...
Ob die beim Waschen zum Beispiel auch kaputt gehen oder ob Wasser denen gar nichts schadet, was ja auch durchaus sein kann, dass das nicht mal der Fall ist.
Nö, passiert nichts.
Passiert nichts, ne?
Das ist entsprechend, wenn dann bloß Magnete, die dann vielleicht doch irgendwo noch benutzt werden könnten, für so ein Zuhause, sagt man nimmt einen großen Magnet und geht immer über seine Sachen. Jetzt nur für die Leute, die da wirklich paranoid sind, aber gut. Nee, wenn du die E-Mail-Adresse uns später nochmal sagst, dann bin ich auch später irgendwann mal drinnen und kann sie mir auch beschreiben, weil ich jetzt gerade auch noch unterwegs bin.
Wird im Rahmen der Sendung nochmal fallen. Und wie groß ist dieser Markt, nur weil du sagst, du bist ja jetzt auch bei so einer Firma tätig, springen da jetzt auch mehr auf den Zug auf, jetzt wo das so langsam publik wird, oder wie viele sind da ungefähr schon dabei?
Also die größeren Kaufhausketten, die ja dann auch, sag ich mal, in ihrer gesamten Gruppe dann wirklich mehrere Namen haben, ich sag nur Jena ist halt Karstadt, die auch RT Wertheim mit drin haben und das KDW, die sind schon dabei. Größere andere Firmen haben sie jetzt auch alle. Also es sind im Augenblick wirklich bloß die großen Kaufhäuser, die auch entsprechend da dann wirklich Inventur-Einbußen haben, die sich dann in solche höheren Gefäßen begeben, dass sich die Investition für diese Technik auch erst.
Was kostet das so im Schnitt? Also pro Artikel, wie viel kostet das?
Das sind Fennigbeträge, weil das in der Massenproduktion geht. Da tritt man halt an Hugo Boss ran und da laufen Rahmenverträge, dass in der Art und Weise Hugo Boss direkt dort dann schon die Chips mit eingenäht hat, ins Futter, irgendwo in die entsprechende Stelle und dort eigentlich, sag ich mal, das wird dann geliefert, die machen das dann gleich mit. Da schiebt man die Gelder hin und her und dann läuft das.
Nutzt Hugo Boss das deines Wissens denn auch für logistische Geschichten, also dass sie dann sagen, wenn so und so viel ist da und dahin gegangen und wir können das zurückverfolgen, dass es dann auch wirklich verkauft worden und so?
Das weiß ich nicht, das weiß ich leider nicht. Also weil wir sind eigentlich nur in der Sicherheitsbranche, in der Art und Weise, dass wir die Überwachung machen, die Technik dafür liefern und dort nur direkt mit den Firmen Verträge abschließen. Also Rahmenverträge werden abgeschlossen mit den Herstellern von den Artikeln, Produkten. In der Art und Weise bei Elektronik ist es natürlich noch einfacher. Da sind heutzutage eigentlich schon überall. Aber jetzt gerade so in die Richtung Kleidung wird es immer mehr kommen, weil da die Diebstähle eigentlich auch meistens sind, wenn man das gesamte statistische Feld betrachtet.
Was heißt, bei Elektronik ist es schon überall?
Naja, ich sag mal, die Edel-Elektronik in der Richtung ist in der Art schon ausgestattet, ja. Die ganzen teure Technik, wo die Anlagen dann schon eine 4-stellig, 5-stellig kosten, die sind meistens in der Art auch schon ausgestattet. Das macht dann aber die Hersteller von der Elektronik schon mit.
Stefan, das würde mich interessieren, du sagst, dass es am Anfang schon auch Anwendungsbeispiele für diese Koppelungen mit Videokameras gibt. Kannst du uns davon ein Beispiel nennen?
Ja, da kann ich es ja noch mehr zu sagen als zu der anderen Geschichte, weil das ist ja nicht mehr mit Che eigentlich. Also das geht teilweise so weit, dass Videoüberwachung direkt mit Kassensystemen zum Beispiel zusammengeschalten wird, mit Zutrittskontrollsystem, das dann dort parallel zum Videomonitor, einem Computermonitor läuft, der nicht nur die Artikel auflistet, die dort gerade rübergezogen werden, die dann mit der Kamera verbindet, dann Zutrittskontrolle in der Art, die Angestellten haben alle einen Chip bekommen, das ist der Beispiel. Der Chip wird ausgegeben, der Chip wird auf jeden Angestellten zugelassen, er hat halt seine Nummer, seine ID, seine Kennung und er öffnet da jeden Tag so seine Karte, sein Büro mit oder seine entsprechenden Bereiche, die er betreten darf. Jetzt will aber der Chef wissen, wo ist denn mein Angestellter? Und wenn er nicht gerade seinen Schlüsselbund mit dem Chip auf dem Schreibtisch schüttelt, dann gibt er bloß eigentlich in seinen Computer die Namen ein und dieses System weiß genau, in welchem Raum sich der Chip im Endeffekt befindet.
Und schaltet wahrscheinlich gleich die Kamera in einem Raum ein.
Die Kamera für den Raum wäre noch aktiviert und er kann den Kollegen genau überwachen.
Big Brother.
Das ist an sich jetzt, sag ich mal, das ist schon in der Art und Weise, ob es jetzt nun wirklich so professionell ist oder nur eine einfache Variante, das ist eigentlich schon seit Jahren praktiziert. In größeren Firmen, gerade in Firmen, die diese in Sicherheit relevante Dinge haben.
Und da wissen die Mitarbeiter das alle, wie es läuft?
Das ist, ich sag mal so jetzt ja. Wie weit ich es dann wirklich wissen, ist immer die andere Sache. Bei manchen Firmen, keine Ahnung, also meistens wird der Betriebsrat informiert. Wenn die ein Betriebsrat haben. Aber es gibt auch oft Fälle, also früher als wir das noch unabhängig klein gemacht haben, als wir noch nicht zu den Großen gehört haben, da haben wir dann wirklich schon mal ganz früher auch zu Firmen Videoüberwachung installiert in Spionagebereichen, also mit Spionkameras in Brandmeldern, in Uhren, in der Art und Weise, in die im Gestellten wussten nicht, dass das da ist.
Tauber, klar rechtswidrig und schadensersatzpflichtig.
Genau so sieht es aus.
Aber was er nicht weiß, macht ihm nicht heißen in der Art. Und der Chef weiß es und der Chef kontrolliert seine Leute, also in der Art und Weise.
Schreib doch mal eine sehr umfangreiche Mail an 84atchaosradio.cc.de, weil allein, dass wir deine E-Mail-Adresse haben, dann mal zurückfragen können, wenn wir was wissen wollen. Das ist schon Gold wert für den Chaos Computer Club.
Nee, keine Angst. Also wie gesagt, das wäre schon mal interessant, ob diese Chips dann einfach deaktiviert werden oder ob die dann praktisch im System freigeschaltet wird. Also jetzt gar nicht mehr, dass sie großartig ausgenutzt wird, aber dass wir schon mal einen Überblick haben, wieso dieser Flow ist, wie denn diese Geschäftsabläufe quasi im Groben da sind. Das wäre schon mal interessant auch.
Na gut, dann müssen sich die Kollegen von der entsprechenden Querenzierung wenden. Da kriege ich sicherlich mal eines raus. Aber wie gesagt, die Adresse noch mal später nennen, weil wir keine Schreibmöglichkeiten haben.
Vielen Dank für den Anruf, Stefan. Und ich habe das erste Mal Frank Rosengard mega-ungläubig nach hinten sinken sehen, weil darauf war auch Frank Rosengard nicht vorbereitet. Das ist toll, ein Erlebnis heute Abend im Chaos Computer Club Radio, im Chaos Radio. Ihr könnt weiter anrufen, 031 77 97 110, wenn ihr auch in der Quellensicherung tätig seid. Wir haben euch gerne. Ihr könnt euch auch melden und erzählen, also wenn ihr in der Branche unterwegs seid. Das ist ja wirklich mal ein Einblick, den man haben möchte, weil eigentlich sind das alles schon Geschichten, die ich doch ganz gerne wissen möchte, wenn ich als Kunde irgendwo unterwegs bin, dass diese Technologie teilweise schon so breit eingeführt worden ist.
Das möchte ich nicht nur wissen, sondern da hab ich auch ein Recht drauf, dass das entsprechend mir alles erzählt wird. Und ich fand das jetzt auch überraschend, dass der Stefan da eigentlich von einer weitgehenden Markeinführung spricht, ist mir völlig neu.
Ja mir ist auch ein bisschen unwohl. Wenn euch auch unwohl ist, ihr könnt das auch gerne kommentieren, Berliner und Brandenburger. Im Studio der Nils, der Frank und der Max. Und am Telefon ist jetzt der René, namens René.
Ja hallo.
Das erste, was ich loswerden will, obwohl ich dachte, dass ich schon früh rankomme, ist, es hört sich ziemlich apokalyptisch an. Und damit komme ich eigentlich zu meiner Frage.
Hallo?
Ja, wir sind da. Wir verarbeiten noch.
Ganz kurze Frage. Ich höre mich laut, obwohl das Radio aus ist. Ich habe so einen Schall, aber ich höre euch ein bisschen leiser.
Wir tun unser Bestes.
Schwierig zu sagen, was da gerade dümmelig läuft.
Okay, wenn ich hier rein spreche, dann habe ich so einen Schall um meine Ohren.
Wir hören nicht jedenfalls prima, dass es richtig ist.
Auf jeden Fall.
Also meine Frage ist, es kommt jetzt so rüber, hier werden Daten gesammelt und ich bin ja... Mist, jetzt habe ich den Faden zwar noch da und die andere Frage ist, was ist das für Daten, die datenrechtlich geschützt sind? Das sind ja eigentlich nur Grunddaten.
Jetzt muss ich eine Antwort geben.
Die wirklichen Informationen, worauf es ankommt, gibt man selbst, ohne dass sie geschützt sind.
Und jetzt komme ich eigentlich zu meiner Frage.
Abgesehen von den ganzen Ships, abgesehen von den ganzen Informationen, die man hinausträgt oder gibt, es sind ja immer Einzelpersonen bzw. Zusammenschlüsse von Personen. Inwiefern kann eine bzw. kann ein Zusammenschluss von Personen die Daten, die ich gebe durch das, was ich einbringe, durchgebe, auswerten, dass ich nicht Gefahr laufe zu denken, jetzt wissen die zu viel über mich?
Das war ja so eine Multi-Frage. Also du meinst, wie viel von deinen Daten kannst du beruhigt preisgeben, ohne dass du Angst haben musst, dass die oder was?
Wo sind die Grenzen?
Kann ich überhaupt Angst haben, dass die Person, die meine Daten bekommt, so kompetent ist, mich übers Ohr zu hauen?
Ja klar.
Inwiefern?
Im Zweifelsfall ist immer irgendwie einer so kompetent. Also das habe ich gelernt. Irgendeiner ist immer kompetent und fies genug.
Und ich habe jetzt schon wieder mehr Informationen gegeben, als Daten rechtlich geschützt ich mich auch absichern kann dadurch. Weil ich so blöd war, diese Frage zu stellen.
Klar, sicher, du zeigst Interesse. Aber es ist durchaus eine schwierige Geschichte, weil das haben wir heute Abend schon mehrfach. Also diese Sache einzuschätzen, wann gebe ich überhaupt Informationen preis, ist ja schon eine Unmöglichkeit. Also in 50 Prozent der Fälle kann ich das ja überhaupt nicht hinterfragen.
Vielleicht habe ich einen Teil von der Frage so verstanden. Also es geht natürlich auch erst mal darum zu trennen, sind hier überhaupt geschützte persönliche Daten von einer Person unterwegs? Also es kann natürlich wirklich sein, dass ein Gerät, ein Pullover, ein irgendwas ausgestattet ist mit so einem RF-Tag, der bestimmte Daten sendet. Diese Daten aber eben nicht zurückführen auf dich zum Beispiel, René, als Person, sondern diese Daten einfach völlig ohne Personenbezug bleiben und nur eine bestimmte Kennung abgeben und nicht auf dich zurückführbar sind. Und dann würde man natürlich in der Tat auch kein Rechtsproblem haben. Kann das sein, dass es in die Richtung auch gegen deine Frage?
Dann muss ich dir eine Gegenantwort geben.
Ich habe eins gelernt.
Ich bin noch ziemlich jung, aber ich habe eine Sache gelernt.
Ich habe geglaubt, die Menschen zu kennen, also mein Umfeld.
Aber was ich nicht berücksichtigt habe, war die Frage, kenne ich mich selbst?
Du wirfst Rätsel auf.
Nein, Rätsel, die man nur so definieren kann, aber jeder versteht es.
Also ich kann da vielleicht eine kurze Antwort dazu. Ich glaube, in dem Moment bist du auf dem guten Weg, dich selber kennenzulernen, wenn du weißt, was deine Umgebung von dir weiß. Denn das ist einfach ein hoher Kontrolleffekt, den du für dich selber erlangst. Und dann hast du eine gute Chance, über dich auch mehr zu erfahren. Das ist so, was mir da so einfällt.
Okay, dann hab ich, ich hab was gegeben und ich kann mich glücklich schätzen, dass ich auch was bekommen habe.
Ja, das ist ja auch eine Geschenkestunde heute.
Vielen Dank für den Anruf.
Ja, ich bin zwei Adidas-Schuhe. Am Telefon ist der Matthias. Wir machen, bevor Matthias jetzt zum Zuge kommt, sagen wir mal so, wir haben ja dieses Interview vorbereitet, das wir auch versprochen haben. Wir haben jetzt folgende Chancen. Entweder wir vertrösten jetzt Matthias, der natürlich schon weiß, dass er rankommt, über die Nachrichten hinweg, was der Hammer wäre, weil das wären dann 15 Minuten. Matthias, wie hältst du davon? Na ja, wir haben jetzt ein Interview aufgezeichnet. Das hieß, wir haben 11 Minuten Interview plus noch mal 4 Minuten Nachrichten. Da würdest du noch mal eine Viertelstunde lang Däumchen drehen können. Natürlich interessiert Däumchen drehen können, weil du hörst ja ein Interview. Oder wir reden jetzt mit dir und machen es nach den Nachrichten. Was sagt die Crew?
Wie viele Anrufe haben wir denn noch?
Also wir haben jetzt hier noch den, also es ist ein bisschen leerer geworden. Ich kann nur empfehlen, Berlin und Brandenburg, ihr habt ja euch vorhin ja richtig überschlagen. Ihr könnt wieder anrufen, die Lounge ist frei.
Dann machen wir noch eine Woche die Anrufe jetzt vor den Nachrichten, ein bisschen Musik und dann danach das Interview.
So schnell wird das demokratisch entschieden.
Matthias, du bist dran.
Wunderbar, super. Also hallo erstmal. Und zwar wollte ich einfach erzählen, dass wir das bei uns in der Firma einsetzen. Und zwar ist es ganz einfach so, wir haben ja Gleitzeit bei uns und jeder Mitarbeiter hat so ein kleines Plastikhärtchen. Und wenn man morgens kommt, dann hält man das an so einem Ding dran und sieht dann, dass man jetzt eingestempelt ist. Und wenn man geht, stempelt man wieder aus. Und ja, so wird dann halt die Zeit mit erfasst. Ja, erstmal nur das. Und dann sind sämtliche Türen, die irgendwo geöffnet werden können, werden auch über diese Karte gesteuert. Das heißt, ich denke, da ist halt irgendwo so eine Personalnummer drin. Und ja, da wird dann drüber gesteuert, wo ich rein darf, wo ich nicht rein darf und solche Sachen halt.
Was haben die für eine Reichweite ungefähr?
Man muss es schon an die Karten, an diese Geräte dranhalten. Aber das hat den Vorteil, also ich kann es im Geldbeutel haben oder im Rucksack oder in der Handtasche. Das sieht immer ganz lustig aus, wenn dann die Mitarbeiter kommen und halten dann ihre Handtasche oder die Jacke oder so an das Gerät und plötzlich geht die Tür auf oder so.
Und also das ist bei euch, war das Thema, wann ist denn das eingeführt worden? Ist das schon lange oder?
Das ist schon ziemlich lange da, also vorher gab es halt auch diese Stempelkarten und ja, also...
Und gab es da schon mal wirklich eine Auswertung, die publik gewesen wäre nach dem Motto so, der Müller muss gehen, weil der Müller ist immer eine Stunde früher gegangen und das haben wir gesehen oder sowas, also dass ihr wirklich spürbar was damit zu tun gehabt hättet oder ist das jetzt so Alltagsgeschichte?
Das ist ziemlich Alltagsgeschichte vor allen Dingen, weil die Leute haben ja alle Gleitzeiten, das heißt, du kannst ja nicht sagen, geht jetzt oder kommt jetzt. Aber was halt spürbar ist oder jeder weiß, jeder der halt irgendwie Zugriff auf das System hat, ich glaube, es wird über SAP oder so ausgewertet, der kann halt sehen, wie viele Stunden ich über oder drunter habe und wann ich gekommen bin und wann ich gegangen bin.
Und einem Kollegen deinen Schlüssel mitgeben für eine Woche und du bleibst zu Hause, wäre doch auch mal geil.
Funktioniert wunderbar, ja. Ja klar, ich meine, der kann ja nicht identifizieren, ob der wirklich anwesend ist oder nicht.
Und wie ist das so in anderen Anwendungsgebieten, also gerade so im Supermarkt oder als Kreditkarte, Geld, als elektronisches Portemonnaie, als BVG-Schein, wie sagt dir das zu? Kannst du dich damit anfreunden oder ist dir das eher nicht so angenehm?
Ich hab's jetzt schon erlebt, auch in so einem Schwimmbad, wo ich auch einen Schlüssel hatte, wo man vorher irgendwie Zeit gespeichert hat, wann ich reinkomme und dann halt, wann ich wieder rausgehe. Und ich finde, in solchen Bereichen ist es echt in Ordnung, auch, dass ich dann damit irgendwo in den Restaurant zahlen kann und muss dann nicht in der Badehose irgendwo mein Geld mit mir drumtragen oder so. Das finde ich schon praktisch, aber wenn ich dann so die Geschichten mit der BVG höre, dass dann hinterher die halbe Welt weiß, wo ich in welcher U-Bahn-Station wie lange gewesen bin und wo ich täglich hinfahre, also ich denke, das sind Daten, die sollte nicht jeder wissen. Weil ich meine, ich könnte ja eine interessante Persönlichkeit sein und irgendjemand, der halt ein bisschen spitzfindiger ist, der weiß dann, wann ich morgens wo zur Arbeit gehe und weiß dann vielleicht auch, wo er mich irgendwie am besten abfahren kann oder was weiß ich was. Also da kann man sich ja alles Mögliche ausdenken. Von daher, also ich denke, es gibt Bereiche, wo diese Technik einem echt weiterhelfen kann, wo das sinnvoll ist, aber man muss da wirklich abwägen. Wo wird es kritisch und es sind halt so Sachen, die mich wirklich ziemlich persönlich treffen.
Ja und auch im Betrieb würde ich sagen, dass es da einfach eine begrenzte Anzahl von Leuten gibt, die überhaupt einen Anspruch darauf haben zu wissen, wann du kommst und wann du gehst. Auch da muss es natürlich eine klare Regelung geben.
Ganz genau, also wenn ich jetzt diese alten Karten habe, wo ich stempel oder so, da gibt es dann natürlich auch ein paar Leute, die sich das anschauen oder anschauen können und dann vielleicht eine Gehaltsabrechnung daraus machen. Aber es sollten natürlich nicht die Mehrheit sein. Es sollten die Leute sein, die damit wirklich arbeiten müssen und dann ist Schluss. Ich meine, die sind dann wahrscheinlich auch so überflutet von Daten, dass die vielleicht gar nicht mehr unter den einzelnen Personen unterscheiden. Aber wenn ich jetzt als interessierte Person dahingehe, dann suche ich mir die Einzelnen raus und es ist ja nicht so toll.
Hat der Betriebsrat oder wenn ihr überhaupt einen habt, sich damit beschäftigt, also dass das Ganze auch für euch koscher abläuft oder ist das Interesse da relativ klein?
Ich denke, dass der Betriebsrat sich damit beschäftigt hat, weil wir haben einen und der muss das abgesegnet haben. Ich denke, insofern läuft das schon erstmal koscher ab. Was jetzt wirklich passiert, weiß natürlich nie jemand. Inwiefern Leute Zugriff zum System haben oder so, das ist halt das ewige Thema.
Hat mal einer einen Schlüssel verloren, so ein Teil?
Ja, das kommt häufiger vor. Da hat man dann die Möglichkeit, in der Personalabteilung anzurufen, zu sagen, ich bin jetzt da und ich gehe jetzt wieder oder so.
Und diese Dinge werden dann einfach, bestimmte Identifikationsschlüssel werden dann einfach deaktiviert und da kommt ein neuer oder muss dann da irgendwas ausgetauscht werden? Weil das wäre ja eigentlich eine billige Variante, wenn da mal so ein richtiger Büroschlüssel verloren geht, wenn das elektronisch endbar ist, ist ja cool.
Ja, ich meine, da kriege ich halt eine neue Karte und ich denke, die wird dann einfach neu codiert. Also mir ist das jetzt persönlich noch nicht passiert und dann funktioniert das wieder, ja.
Die alte wird dann gesperrt einfach, klar.
Wahrscheinlich, ja. Wo wir gerade davon sprechen, da fällt mir auch gerade was ein. Ich weiß, dass irgendwo in Stuttgart soll da eingeführt werden, dass Tourenhallen und so weiter über so ein System verarbeitet werden sollen. Und zwar sollen dann Sportvereine und so weiter, die kriegen dann auch so ein Kärtchen und kriegen dann nicht einfach mehr einen Schlüssel für eine Tourenhalle, sondern die Karte. Und die Karte ist dann für so und so viele Stunden oder für die Zeit von dann bis dann freigeschaltet. Und dann kann der Sportverein halt da rein trainieren und wieder raus und danach hat er dann keinen Zugriff mehr auf die Halle. Also ich denke, in solchen Bereichen ist das vielleicht auch eine sinnvolle Sache, weil günstiger Schlüssel im Prinzip. Und ich hab halt wirklich Kontrolle, dass ich kann sagen, der kann nur von dann bis dann rein und nicht vorher und nicht später.
Wie ist denn das Problem der Beweislast, wenn da tatsächlich denn irgendwas passiert? Und ich war da aber nicht in der Halle. Und jetzt hat aber das System registriert, dass da irgendwie mit meiner Karte aber die Tür geöffnet wurde. Dann bin ich ja quasi dann als der Geschädigte. Also ich muss ja dann irgendwie beweisen, dass ich da nicht war.
Und wie das genau abläuft, also ich bin auch kein Rechtsfachmann.
Naja, das ist natürlich die Frage dann, ob tatsächlich eben solche technische Infrastrukturen nicht dazu führen, dass im Grunde unsere normalen Möglichkeiten eben ein Beweis zu führen, zurücktreten hinter der Überzeugungskraft und dieser Authentizität eigentlich dieser Systeme. Das ist natürlich eine Diskussion, die auch schon länger geführt wird, auch im Datenschutzbereich, dass auch eben solche Beweislastverschiebungen stattfinden. Du musst im Grunde dann erstmal erklären, wieso das System da ganz anderer Meinung ist als du in deiner Darstellung. Und das sind natürlich Gefahren, die auch entsprechend dann Regelungen brauchen im Recht.
Wobei im Prinzip kann mir das mit einem normalen Schlüssel ja auch passieren, dass ich den verliere oder weitergebe und jemand anderes geht dann damit rein und dann heißt es, ich hab ja diesen Schlüssel gehabt.
Ja, aber andere hatten ihn auch noch. Und im Prinzip ist ja nicht sichergestellt, dass genau dein Schlüssel des Vadeos aufgeschlossen hat. Was ja dann jetzt mit den Chips so ist vermutlich dann.
Ja, gern geschehen.
Tschüss.
So, wie gesagt, wir reden gleich weiter hier im Chaos Radio auf Fritz. Wir haben Halbzeit, wir haben es halb zwölf, das heißt es ist noch genug Zeit. Ich schau mal eben auf mein Zettelchen. Ja, ich habe alles vorliegen, denn wir machen jetzt erst mal Nachrichten. Danach geht es weiter. Wir haben, wie gesagt, ein kleines Interview aufgezeichnet mit einem Spezi, der sich damit auseinandergesetzt hat, was da so für kleine Fallen warten, was diese ganzen Chips anbelangt. Das gibt es gleich nach den Nachrichten. Wenn ihr das also hören wollt, bleibt dabei.
Wenn Fritz in der Friednis, dann 103, 1.
23.30 gleich.
Fritz Info.
Mit dem Wetter, abends und nachts, ziehen so ein paar Wolken durch bei 17 bis 13 Grad. Die verabschieden sich aber auch dann wieder. Morgen früh scheint erstmal die Sonne. Später gibt es einen Vereinzeltschauer oder Gewitter bei maximal 27 bis 30 Grad. Jetzt die Meldung mit Matthias Kerkhoff.
Bei der umstrittenen Arbeitszeit für Lehrer haben sich Berliner Senat und die Gewerkschaften noch nicht geeinigt. Das sagte der Regierende Bürgermeister Woverheit nach rund vier stündigen Verhandlungen. Woverheit stellte klar, dass der Senat die Erhöhung der Pflichtstundenzahl für angestellte Lehrer nicht zurücknehmen wird. Alleinerziehende sollen künftig mit einem monatlichen Zuschlag von 20 Euro pro Kind unterstützt werden. Das berichtet die Financial Times. Danach sollen Familien mit einem Jahreseinkommen von maximal 30.000 Euro diese Beihilfe bekommen. Das Lidikum Frankfurt Oder will Anzeige gegen Unbekannt erstatten. Bei dem Einbau der Wasserleitungen soll ein schwere Fehler gemacht worden, sagte der zuständige Vorstand des Klinikträgers der Bildzeitung. Das Klinikum trage für die Todesfälle keine Verantwortung. In dem Krankenhaus waren zwei Menschen an der seltenen Likionierskrankheit gestorben. Zum Sport. Der Fußball-Bundesligist Wolfsburg steht so gut wie sicher. In einem der Finale des UICUPS im Halbfinale-Hinspiel siegten die Wolfsburger gegen Kroatien mit 4 zu 1. Und der Verkehr rollt für wünschen gute Fahrt.
Morgen Abend. Film-Bluemoon-Spezial.
Mit MC-Lücke. Der Fritz-Film-Bluemoon live aus dem Kubiksuferpalast Alexanderplatz. Wie immer mit Fritz-Filmexperte Ronald Blum und einem einzigen Thema. Terminator 3. Die Rückkehr des Terminators Anni ist weg. Aber bringt er es noch als Terminator? Und wie wirken sich eigentlich Falten bei einer Maschine aus? Der Fritz-Film-Bluemoon live aus dem Kubiksuferpalast Alexanderplatz in der Rathorstrasse 1 in Berlin-Mitte.
Der Film-Bluemoon-Spezial. Morgen Abend ab 22 Uhr. Und im Radio Fritz.
Ich. Ein bisschen Musik zur Entspannung im Chaosradio.
Von Nitram, nicht aufgelegt, aber vor aufgelegt sozusagen und uns hier als Mixtape reingereicht. Für drei Stunden das, was ihr im Hintergrund hört, zusammen gemixt von Nitram.
Wir müssen natürlich auch mal Musik spielen, denn das Thema heute Abend lässt einen schon so ein bisschen verspannen in der Rückengegend, weil sich einige, wie wir merken, die hier ihr anruft aus Berlin und Brandenburg, schon so ihre Gedanken darüber machen, wofür das, worüber wir heute Abend sprechen, so zu benutzen ist. Und wenn ihr gerade erst eingeschaltet habt, gibt es noch mal eine kleine Einführung im Studio. Das sind der Nils von der Humanistischen Union, vom Chaos Computer Club selbst, natürlich der Frank und meine Person Max von Malott. Gibt ein Thema die Einführung, die Kleine gibt es noch mal von Frank.
Wir beschäftigen uns heute mit kontaktlosen Chipkarten, sogenannte RFID-Tags oder Klebetiketten auch, die per Funk über die Daten übermitteln. Die Dinger können eingesetzt werden anstelle von den bisherigen Barcodes, von den Strichcodes auf Lebensmitteln oder auf sonstigen Artikeln. Die können aber auch Anwendung finden bei zum Beispiel anstelle des BVG-Fahrscheins oder auch auf Geldscheinen, um die Dinger dann zu identifizieren. Und die Dinger werden also über Funk ausgelesen, das heißt, sie müssen keine Chipkarte mehr irgendwo reinstecken, sondern geht damit irgendwo vorbei an ein Lesegerät, zieht die Karte irgendwo lang. Es kann aber auch über längere Entfernung wie ein ein oder zwei Meter ausgelesen werden, wo ihr dann einfach nur durch eine Schranke durchgeht und alles, was ihr am Körper tragt, wird dann erfasst zum Beispiel.
Das Ganze hat natürlich die Beobachtung verschiedenster Leute gefunden und wir haben auch für den heutigen Abend Experten im Interview befragt. Das hört ihr jetzt.
So, hallo, wir haben hier am Telefon den Volker Bürk aus Ulm vom CCC, vom RFR-Kreis Ulm. Und der Volker hat sich schon mal ein bisschen mit RFIDs, also mit Transponder-Card, mit Chipkarten beschäftigt und arbeitet da derzeit auch in einem Projekt und weiß daher auch schon ein bisschen, wie es in der Praxis aussieht. Volker, wie funktioniert eigentlich genau diese RFID-Technologie?
Also die Grundidee ist, dass man Daten drahtlos überträgt. Also sprich, vielleicht kennst du eine oder andere schon, das ist RFID, wenn man so Karten hat, vielleicht in der Bildungseinrichtung oder beim Arbeitgeber. Und man muss diese Karten nur noch in die Nähe eines Kästchen halten und muss sie, die haben keinen Magnetstreifen mehr, man muss sie nicht mehr durchziehen. Also die Grundidee daran ist halt, dass man drahtlos Daten überträgt, entweder über Funk, was am häufigsten ist, ältere Systeme machen das über Induktion.
Und wie ist denn so ein Ding aufgebaut? Da ist dann irgendwie eine Antenne drin und ein Chip oder wie sieht das aus?
Also grundsätzlich sind die Dinger in etwa so aufgebaut, da ist eine Antenne und an dieser Antenne hängt eben irgendein analogischer Schaltkreis, der dort Signale entgegennimmt und auch wieder auswenden kann. Man spricht auch von Transponder-Technik. Und das Ganze ist verbunden mit einem digitalen Schaltkreis und dieser digitale Schaltkreis ist dann bei den etwas älteren Geräten schlichtweg ein herkömmlicher von Neumann-Rechner, also eine CPU und Arbeitsspeicher und solche Dinge.
Sind da Batterien drin oder wie kriegen die ihren Strom?
Das ist verschieden. Es gibt Geräte, die sogenannte passive Geräte, die beziehen ihren Saft schlichtweg aus demjenigen, der da mit einem Signal anfrägt und beziehen den Saft aus diesem Signal. Das ist aber ein bisschen kitzlig, weil in Kubisch mit der Entfernung nimmt die Signalsteuerung mit dem Saft ab. Also auf längere Entfernung haben die Dinge dann, wenn sie auf längere Entfernung funktionieren wollen, haben die Batterien.
Und in welchen Erscheinungsformen kommen diese Transponder, diese Tags vor? Also wie sind die in der Praxis so in freier Wildbahn dann vorhanden?
Also in der Praxis finden man Tags inzwischen in ziemlich unterschiedlichen Erscheinungsformen. Zum einen eben diese Karten, die vorhin nannte, zum anderen sind das heute aber auch einfach kleine Computerchips, könnte man sagen. Und die findet man zum Beispiel in Form von Aufklebern. Aber da ist die Dinger inzwischen, also ich habe Geräte gesehen, das runter zur Stecknadelkopfgröße, kann man die auch super irgendwo ankleben und verstecken.
Okay. Wie ist denn die Reichweite von den Dingern? Wie weit funktionieren die vom, also der Abstand zwischen diesem Transponder und dem Lesegerät?
Das ist sehr unterschiedlich. Die passiven Transponder funktionieren nach meiner Erfahrung so zwischen, ja, sagen wir mal, mit einem halben Meter Entfernung funktionieren die sehr gut. Mit so einhalb Meter Entfernung, maximal zwei Meter Entfernung, funktionieren sie einigermaßen brauchbar. Wer da wesentlich weiter weg will, muss wahrscheinlich noch eine Batterie nehmen dann.
Jetzt gibt es so in den Medien Anwendungsbeispiele oder Warnberichte über Fade Versuche, die gemacht werden, zum Beispiel im Supermarkt, dass ich dann die ganzen Artikel, die ich einkaufe, mit diesen Tags ausgestattet habe, die packe ich in meinen Einkaufswagen und gehe damit dann zur Kasse. Und da soll dann aber keine Kassiererin mehr sitzen, sondern da werden die Sachen dann praktisch eingescannt, per Funk eingescannt. Wenn ich jetzt aber so einen Wocheneinkauf habe für eine vierköpfige Familie mit vielleicht, weiß nicht, 50, 100 Sachen drin, geht das denn? Also stören die sich nicht gegenseitig?
Also grundsätzlich geht sowas. Die Idee bei diesen Supermarktkassen ist ja, dass man die Produkte dann einzeln daran vorbei bewegt. Also so ähnlich wie vielleicht bei den Barcodes kennen. Nur halt muss man nicht mehr so nahe hin. Deshalb kann man das dann quasi selber machen. Und man muss auch nicht mehr so genau die Richtung treffen wie bei den Barcodes. Also ich denke schon, dass das praktikabel ist. Grundsätzlich gibt es natürlich das Problem, dass wenn sehr viele Transponder-Chips auf einem Haufen sind, dass man sogenannte Kollisionen bekommt. Also so das Auflösen von, ich sag mal zwischen 10 und 20, maximal 30 Kollisionen, das geht dann noch einigermaßen brauchbar. Und was da deutlich, wenn da deutlich die Zeit rüber ist, dann wird das sehr schwierig.
Und wie ist es in der Praxis? Gibt es da häufig Fehler oder sind die Systeme schon ganz gut ausgereift mittlerweile?
Also ich habe eher so die Erfahrung gemacht, dass es noch häufig Fehler gibt. Das liegt allerdings auch daran, momentan herrscht ein Riesenwust von unterschiedlichen Standards und Normen. Also die unterschiedlichen Normungsgremien stürzen sich gerade drauf und arbeiten da auch kräftig dran. Und dann gibt es noch sehr viele Implementierungen, die sind überhaupt nicht standardisiert. Und ja, also es gibt auch verschiedene Probleme mit der Übertragung von diesen Daten. Also wie werden die Daten dann übertragen? Wird nicht verschlüsselt übertragen oder nicht verschlüsselt? Und dann gibt es natürlich so Probleme wie, durch Metalldurch kann man halt nicht funken. Das heißt, sobald da irgendwo Metall dazwischen ist, geht es gar nicht. Und wenn Metall außen rum ist, gibt es eben Reflexionen, die stören. Und dann eben die üblichen Signalüberlagungsprobleme. Also es gibt Transponder, die arbeiten in ähnlichen Frequenzbereichen wie Wavelan und haben aber nicht diese Möglichkeiten von Wavelan, dass man eben so durch Channel-Hopping den Orgel ausgleicht, sage ich mal. Und entsprechend gibt es da durchaus Probleme mit dem Funken mit den Dingen.
Du hast gesagt, durch Metall wird das irgendwie gestört. Könnte man das dann auch gezielt einsetzen, wenn ich jetzt meinetwegen in einer Brieftasche so eine Chipkarte habe und will nicht, dass sie ausgelesen wird, dass ich dann so einen Metallkäfig rummache?
Ja, also ich würde sie halt in Alufolie einpacken und das war's dann.
Okay, und das hilft auch mit Sicherheit dann Alufolie rum und das hilft mit Sicherheit, ja.
Also ich kenne keine Möglichkeit, wie man durch Metall funken kann.
Okay, du hast gesagt, da gibt es verschiedene Standards und da ist ein ziemliches Kuddelmuddel. Ist denn tatsächlich geplant, diese ganzen Standards dann zu einem gemeinsamen Standard zu kommen, dass ich dann auch mit unterschiedlichen Systemen oder mit einem System unterschiedliche Karten auslesen kann, die ich vielleicht vorher noch nicht so gekannt habe, also ähnlich jetzt vielleicht wie es bei Bluetooth ist oder sowas, wo ich dann einfach irgendein Gerät nehmen kann und das irgendwo neben einem anderes Gerät und die sehen sich dann, unterhalten sich und können möglicherweise auch Sachen austauschen. Wird das irgendwann deiner Meinung nach so sein, dass es da so ein System gibt, was dann auch mit den Daten von den anderen Herstellern was anfangen kann?
Also ein System, das mit Daten von anderen Herstellern was anfangen kann, das sicher, weil ja die Normos-Gremien momentan solche Dinge vorlegen, aber es gibt ein großes Problem. Das wird auf jeden Fall bei unterschiedlichen Standards bleiben und das ist das Problem der Energiedichte. Man kann einfach nicht so viel Energie mit den passiven Transponder abstrahlen, die sind aber gleichzeitig finanziell am interessantesten, weil so ein passiver Transponder liegt inzwischen schon zwischen 40 und 50 Cent und aktiver Transponder liegt halt immer ab 2 Euro aufwärts. Und wenn man die wirklich in Maße herstellen will, möchte man natürlich die passiven Transponder haben wegen der Kohle. Und das Problem ist aber, durch die erhöhte Energiedichte, wenn man die Frequenz hochdreht, hat man das Problem, dass man bei den passiven Transponder eher mit niedrigen Frequenzen arbeitet. Die wiederum reichen dann aber nicht so weit, da kann man nicht so wirklich toll damit funken, einfach gesagt. Und man möchte eigentlich die höheren Frequenzen haben, die gehen aber nur mit den aktiven, sodass sich das Ganze vielleicht mal irgendwo in zwei oder drei Gruppen aufspalten wird. So von den Frequenzbereichen her. Also es wird nicht so sein wie bei Bluetooth, dass es wirklich so genormt ist, sondern es wird vielleicht drei große Standards geben oder irgendetwas.
Könnte ich mir vorstellen. Diese aktiven Transponder, die senden denn tatsächlich immer? Oder wie muss ich mir das vorstellen?
Nein, nein, also Transponder senden nicht immer, sondern die reagieren, sobald sie aufgefordert worden sind zu senden. Und die Aufforderungen zu senden, die ist halt sehr verschieden. Also entweder besteht die aus einem einfachen Signal, in dem gar nichts groß reinkodiert ist, und die senden halt mit dieser Energie zurück. Oder aber sobald das Signal eben die Geräte anregt, bei den Passiven zum Beispiel. Oder aber da läuft wirklich so etwas ab. Also bei den ganz ausgefuchsten Geräten läuft umsthaft die Kryptographie mit Schlüsseltausch ab. Also so einfach mal rumsenden tun die nicht, weil sonst wär auch die Aktiven verbrauchen jetzt nicht so viel Saft. Das liegt so im Mikro bis Milliwatt-Bereich. Aber bei Osmog North Batterie in dieser Größe kannst du auch nicht viel rausholen. Und das wär auch ziemliche Energieverschwendung. Also da wird nicht ständig gefunkt.
Wenn ich jetzt, sag ich mal, selbst ein bisschen damit rumspielen will, vielleicht möglicherweise auch mal in der U-Bahn auf die Suche gehen will, was die Leute so in ihren Taschen haben. Gibt es da denn irgendwelche Kids zum Spielen, irgendwelche Sets oder sowas?
Also was du dazu brauchst, ist halt ein Gerät, mit dem man die Dinger anfunkten kann und zum Reden bringen kann. Also ein im Prinzip ein Handlesegerät. Wenn man sich so Handlesegeräte anschaut, dann sind die noch recht teuer, weil die werden meistens einzeln gefertigt. Und je nach Stückzahl hab ich welche gesehen, zwischen zweieinhalb und zehntausend Euro. Also es ist ein teurer Spaß, wenn ich mir irgendwo sowas fertig kaufen will. Vor allem die zehntausend Euro sind es eher, wenn man zwei Stück will oder so. Und ich denke aber, dass das ganze Spiel in sehr kurzer Zeit, also sag mal, lass da mal zwei Jahre vergehen, dann wird das ganze Spiel denke ich sehr günstig werden, weil es überhaupt keinen Grund gibt, weshalb man keine solchen Lesegeräte in großer Auflage demnächst herstellen soll. Und dann gibt es die vielleicht so mit USB-Port zum Anklemmen oder irgend sowas. Und man hat das sicher billig demnächst.
Und damit kann ich dann im Prinzip auch alle Karten auslesen, so sie dann keine verschlüsselte Übertragung haben.
Ja gut, damit kann ich die Karten auslesen, die in diesem Frequenzbereich arbeiten, in dem dein Gerät arbeitet.
Ja, gut, aber im Prinzip schon irgendwie eine Sache, mit der man sich mal beschäftigen könnte in nächster Zeit.
Also das auf jeden Fall. Es ist auch ziemlich spannend, vor allem die, ich finde die Anwendung in der Logistik sehr spannend. Jetzt, ich arbeite jetzt weniger so im Einzelhandel, mehr dann in dem Bereich, man belädt halt LKWs und möchte wissen, was ist da jetzt tatsächlich eingeladen worden in diesem LKW? Solche Dinge zum Beispiel. Und das glaube ich auch sinnvoll. Ich sehe auch eine große Gefahr in den Dingen aus Datenschutzgründen. Also das Problem ist natürlich, ich sehe eine der größten Gefahren darin, dass bei uns hier, ich wohne im Süden in Bad Waldseede, haben sie jetzt bei den Mülleimern RFIDs eingeführt, das ist kein Schatz. Und machen die Abrechnung des Mülls noch nicht kilogrammweise, obwohl die Autos das schon können. Deswegen machen die Abrechnungen des Mülls eben, je nachdem wie oft man abholen lässt pro Person. Wenn man sich jetzt mal vorstellt, dass RFIDs auf den Verpackungen wären, was er kommen soll, kann man sich vorstellen, Das löst unser Pfandproblem wahrscheinlich. Ja, zum Beispiel das Pfandproblem, aber ich sehe dann auch eine schöne Einnahmequelle für die Kommunen, die ja alle Pleite sind oder Kurzförderpleite, dass sie vielleicht die Daten, welche Verbrauche, in welchem Viertel was verbrauchen, dann an die Unternehmen verkaufen könnten, denn die wissen das dann.
Ja, das stimmt.
Gefährlich. Nicht umsonst haben wir dieses Stichwort am Ende des Interviews stehen lassen. Das ist, damit ihr habt ja jetzt mal einen kleinen Überblick, so alles möglich mit diesen kleinen Funkchips, die möglicherweise in Zukunft, in den nächsten Jahren, das ersetzen werden, was auf allen möglichen Sachen drauf ist. Also diese kleinen Kleberchen mit Barcodes oder Ähnliches oder Eingenähtkleidung, wo auch immer. Dieses Beispiel haben wir heute Abend tatsächlich schon gehört, dass Großhersteller Sachen in ihre Kleidung einnähen lassen, um eben halt funkmäßig damit ausgestattet zu sein. Was haltet ihr davon? Ihr hört das Chaos Radio auf, Fritz, wir haben es kurz vor zwölf. Das heißt, wir haben noch eine gute Stunde Zeit. Im Studio ist der Nils von der Humanistischen Union. Buntes Team heute, der Frank vom Chaos Computer Club und meine Person Max von Malodki. 031 77 97 110, die Nummer, wenn ihr euch zum Thema äußern möchtet, Kommentare loswerden oder vielleicht auch nur eure Angst bekämpfen möchtet. Das ist das, was ich momentan tue, indem ich mich hier an dieser hölzernen Tischplatte festkralle. Aber der Frank, der hat so eine sanfte Stimme, die lullt mich dann immer wieder ein und immer dann, wenn die bösen Infos kommen, schreck ich wieder auf.
Die bösen Infos? Wunderbar. Nein, ich habe hier noch so eine Pressemitteilung von Texas Instruments, dass American Express jetzt ein neues Zahlungssystem testet, natürlich auch kontaktlos. Das ist total klasse, das ist auf eure Kreditkarte drauf. Ihr braucht dann beim Bezahlen nicht mehr eure Kreditkarte aus der Tasche ziehen, sondern es wird einfach so abgebucht. Das macht jetzt Sachen mit diesen Supermarktanwendungen natürlich komplett rund. Ihr geht rein in den Supermarkt, der Einkaufswagen, den ihr nehmt, der weiß natürlich schon, was ihr kaufen wollt, weil das habt ihr vorher per Internet oder der Kühlschrank hat es gemeldet. Der lotst euch dann durch den Supermarkt durch, wie in so einem Autonavigationssystem, so mit Pfeil links, jetzt hier rechts zugreifen, dritte Etage von oben und dann ab und zu poppt dann nochmal ein Sonderangebot auf. Das wird dann alles leicht registriert, wenn ihr das in den Einkaufskorb reintut und natürlich dann auch gleich von eurer schönen, bequemen, kontaktlosen Kreditkarte abgebucht. Und dann geht ihr einfach wieder raus aus dem Supermarkt.
Das war's.
Nicht schlecht. Und neben mir steht dann so eine dicke Frau und für die habe ich gleich mit eingekauft. Das sind immer nur meine Fantasien. 0371 77 97 1 1 0. Das Thema ist noch nicht zu Ende besprochen. Am Telefon ist erstmal der Nick, Name? Nick? Du bist mit der ganzen Sache wahrscheinlich nicht so zufrieden, wie ich das in deinem Vibrator in der Stimme schon hören kann, oder?
Und zwar, ich muss sagen, ich finde sogar die Vorstellung relativ pervers, wenn man dann irgendwie rausgeht, man registriert die BVG, wohin man mit dem Bus fährt, an welche S-Bahn man steigt, dann registriert der Laden, welchen Anzug man zum Beispiel kauft, dann gehst du aus dem Laden raus, dann scheint irgendwie auf einer Tafel nach, brauchen sie hier noch die Schuhe dazu, Erdgeschoss, linke, links, drittes Geschäft, die Schuhe dazu holen, und dann ist es halt wirklich wie, ich bin jetzt auch in diesem Payback oder so, und weil ich relativ oft bei Obi einkurve, kriege ich da auch vermehrt solche Briefe und Gutscheine von Obi. Also, dass es halt dann auch noch mehr ausgenutzt wird, habe ich dann halt so, sozusagen die Befürchtung, und dass dann halt wirklich auch die Individualität, dass man da so im Grundgesetz halt einem Menschen garantiert ist, verletzt wird.
Eigentlich ist es ja nicht schlecht, ich meine, die Sonderangebote kannst du natürlich auch besonders gut ausnutzen, wenn man es mal positiv sehen will.
Ja, aber das ist ja, im Endeffekt ist es ja wieder so, dass sie dann schon im Preis, den die dann haben wollen, sowieso schon wieder drin sind. Irgendwie zahlt man ja trotzdem dafür.
Und warum hast du diese Karte überhaupt in Anspruch genommen? Also wieso machst du das denn überhaupt? Du scheinst dir ja offensichtlich Sorgen drum zu machen grundsätzlich.
Na ja, das mit den Karten, das sehe ich mal so. Die haben meinen Namen, meine Adresse und können mir dann so was zustiegen. Aber wenn das wirklich in Zukunft ist, wo dann die Leute halt immer wissen, wo ich bin, das ist ja dann wirklich fast wie 1984 von George Orwell oder so. Kommt mir das dann wirklich langsam so vor, zum Beispiel auch wenn man jetzt einmal durchs Regierungswettbewerb in Berlin geht, ich weiß nicht mal wie viele Kameras man da dann in zehn Minuten dort gefilmt wird oder so. Das finde ich jetzt schon relativ erschreckend, dass man da halt überall überwacht wird.
An den Liegenschaften der Bundesrepublik, also der Bundesverwaltung, die Liegenschaften sozusagen, die haben halt Zahlen rausgegeben auf eine Anfrage und es kam raus, dass im Durchschnitt jede Liegenschaft, also jedes Grundstück, jedes Gebäude des Bundes doppelt so viel Kameras hat, wie im ersten Big Brother Container angebracht waren. Also ich habe das mal ausgerechnet so zum Spaß. Das ist schon sehr erschreckend.
Jedes Gebäude.
Jedes Gebäude hat im Durchschnitt, also die Gesamtzahl durch Anzahl der Gebäude, da kommt dann so eine Zahl raus, wie ich glaube 56 war das oder so, oder um die 60 rum und das sind halt fast doppelt so viel, wie beim Big Brother Container der ersten Staffel Kameras drin waren.
Also die Frage ist bei so einer Sache ja immer, am Ende muss ein Mensch in der Regel die Sachen auswerten, nur wenn jetzt so eine Technik dazu kommt, die einem ermöglicht, bestimmte Daten einfach miteinander zu verquicken, ohne dass grundsätzlich ein Mensch drüber gucken muss, sondern dass du einfach nur was hast, dann kommt auf dem Bildschirm von dem, was weiß ich, Überwacher aufgepoppt, hier ist gerade der und der Typ vorbeigegangen, hat das und das geklaute Item dabei gehabt und nur dann wird ein Bild gezeigt. Dann wird es natürlich auch erst interessant. Vorher ist so ein System ja nicht wirklich interessant, es ist ja eine Masse an Daten, die keiner sichten kann.
Ja, aber das Interessante ist, dass genau diese Entwicklung absehbar kommt. Also letzte Woche lief eine Meldung über einen Ticker, dass die Engländer, die nach wie vor Videoüberwachungsweltmeister sind mit den meisten Kameras der Welt, jetzt eine Software entwickelt haben, die es eben erlaubt, bestimmte Verhaltensmuster zu erkennen. Das heißt, es läuft im Hintergrund der Videokamera, die den Bahnsteig der Tube, der U-Bahn in London überwacht, läuft im Hintergrund eine Software und die scant die anwesenden Personen auf dem Bahnsteig auf ein bestimmtes einprogrammiertes Verhaltensmuster hin. Und zwar hat man dieses Verhaltensmuster bei auf mutmaßliche Selbstmörder hin einprogrammiert. Und damit ist es dem System möglich, sozusagen Alarm zu schlagen, wenn eine des Selbstmordes verdächtige Person sich dort bewegt. Ich meine, das Ding geht natürlich oft genug auch völlig sinnlos. Ohne Grund geht das System los und man wird zu Boden geschmissen vom Sicherheitspersonal, weil man als mutmaßlicher sozusagen angenommen wird. Aber das ist die Entwicklung und da braucht keiner mehr auf die Monitore zu schauen. Und damit ist eigentlich diese Hoffnung auch weg, dass die bloße Masse der Bilder und der Informationen uns schützt und wir quasi darin untergehen.
Stimmt das auch, vor allem nach den Anschlägen vom 11. September, jetzt wieder unter dem Thema Sicherheit?
Kampf gegen den Terror.
Dass sozusagen geschützt wird. Dass man ja sagt, ja, das ist für die allgemeine Sicherheit und wir müssen jetzt sozusagen jeden überwachen. Er könnte dann potenzieller Attentäter sein.
Allein schon der Einkauf im Supermarkt kann auch schon ganz tolle Rückschlüsse darauf geben, was für eine Person sich das handelt. Ich meine, ich nehme einfach nur erstmal alle Leute, die irgendwie ausgefallene Gewürze gekauft haben, wie Kokuma oder viel Ingwer oder sowas, und schließe einfach mal darauf, auf deren Herkunft zum Beispiel.
Genau, dann werden die vielleicht, jetzt von USA, dann müssen sie sich eine nächste Meldestelle oder so erstmal vorzeigen, ausweisen. Oder zum Beispiel, vielleicht wird dann auch, stimmt irgendwie das SEK an eine Wohnung, wenn man irgendwas gekauft hat, an welche Reinigungsmittel, wo man auch potenziell eine Bombe mit herstellen könnte.
Das ist aber lustig, wir hatten ja vorhin das Beispiel mit den Rasierklingen, dass Leute die Rasierklingen kaufen, die oft klauen und dementsprechend eben Leute mit Rasierklingen offensichtlich von Kameras verfolgt werden. Lustig wär natürlich, wenn das MKA zum Testen immer C4-Sprengstoff irgendwo ins Regal tun würde. Mal gucken, wer's kauft. Also ich hatte ne Reportage gesehen, das war ne, die hieß glaube ich Gesichter, war ne BBC-Reportage, sehr schön, mit John Cleese, der das Ganze geführt hat. Und dann hat John Cleese versucht, sich so zu verkleiden, dass das englische Gesichtserkennungssystem ihn nicht erkennen kann. Der ist als alte Frau gegangen, als Fußballholigin, als was weiß ich nicht, was. Und nur wenn der Mund und Augen, also Sonnenbrille und Gesichtsschutz bis zur Nase hoch verwendet hat, hat das System ihn nicht erkannt. Also sobald irgendwas sichtbar war, nur ein Fragment, war die Sache vorbei.
Also das System ist sicherlich noch nicht entwicklungsreif, weil in voller Bewegung sozusagen in wechselnden Lichtverhältnissen nach wie vor eine erhebliche Fehlerquote da ist. Aber es ist ganz klar, da wird unheimlich viel Geld reingebuttert in diese Entwicklung von Erkennungssoftware. Weil das natürlich Perspektiven der Fahndung bietet, die wir heute uns gar nicht vorstellen können. Also über diese Videokameras entsprechend Leute aufzusuchen, auf Plätzen, auf öffentlichen Plätzen, auf G-Steigen. Da wird man weiter untersuchen und wird versuchen, diese Entwicklung voranzutreiben. Mal sehen, ob das gelingt.
Dieses System muss doch noch wahnsinnig fehlerhaft sein, würde ich mal sagen, weil wenn man so jetzt was macht, dann müssen doch im Prinzip sehr hohe Fehlerquoten aufgetreten. Weiß man da schon Zahlen davon? Hat man das schon mal getestet oder?
Also es gibt unterschiedliche Untersuchungen, was die Fehleranfälligkeit angeht. Die Fehlerquoten bei diesen Geräten, bei diesem Gesichtserkennungssystem sind nach wie vor zu hoch, um mit diesem System wirklich tatsächlich in der Realität arbeiten zu können. Aber nichts Genaues weiß man nicht. Auf Genosse gibt es eben auch Projekte, bei denen man überhaupt schlicht nicht erfährt, wie die Zahlen da sind. Und ja, da muss man weiter einfach nachbohren und nachfahren.
Wie zum Beispiel auch bei der BVG, die ja diesen Feldversuch-Ticket gemacht haben und dann auch so eine Begleitstudie gemacht haben. Und da gab es dann so einen Fragebogen danach. Da waren halt eine ganze Menge Fragen drauf. Und es gab eine Auswertung von dieser Studie, so ein Ergebnis. Und dann kam nun raus, dass 95% der Teilnehmer der Testteilnehmer mit dem Datenschutz gar keine Probleme hatten oder da irgendwie keine Schwierigkeiten sahen. Das hätten die Fragebögen ergeben. Allerdings gab es auf dem Fragebogen auch gar keinen Feld, um da irgendwas anzukreuzen oder so. Und ich vermute mal, dass sie dann einfach genommen haben, da war dann auch so eine Textofferbemerkung, wo die Leute frei was eintragen konnten. Und dass sie da einfach 5% der Leute was reingeschrieben haben, dass sie da irgendwie Probleme mit haben. Deswegen haben sie angenommen, die anderen 95% haben da kein Problem mit.
Bloß die Leute nicht auf dumme Gedanken bringen, ne? Nick, wir haben dich nicht wirklich beruhigen können, ne?
Tut uns leid.
Vielen Dank für deinen Anruf. 0331 77 97 110, wenn ihr euch in einer Diskussion beteiligen möchtet. Am Telefon ist der Martin. Hallo Martin.
Mich würde mal interessieren, vor allem bei diesen RFIDs, wie sich denn die Hersteller und der Handel vor allem vor Sabotage schützen wollen. Also ich meine, das ist ja Elektronik, das ist ja Hightech. Und wir alle wissen ja, das Zeug geht auch kaputt. Ach. Ja, wenn so ein Ding nicht funktioniert. Ich denke jetzt zum Beispiel auf das Beispiel im Schwimmbad. Also wenn ich mir vorstelle, ich habe da so einen Teil am Schlüssel und ich bin eine halbe Stunde im Schwimmbad und ziehe das irgendwie über einen mitgebrachten 9 Volt Block oder so das Ding aus, dann bleibe ich halt 5 Stunden da. Wenn ich raus gehe, sage ich halt, gut, dass das kaputt ist, das ist nicht mein Problem und ich war halt hier eine halbe Stunde drin. Also irgendwie, denke ich, müssen die ja vor Manipulation geschützt sein, diese Dinger.
Das ist wahrscheinlich auch wieder diese Beweislastfrage, wer dann letztendlich beweisen muss, dass das System nicht funktioniert, dass das System dann Fehler gemacht hat oder so. Also vielleicht gerade bei diesem Beispiel, wenn es kaputt ist, dann ist wahrscheinlich...
Die können ja von dir nicht erwarten, dass du keine Magneten in der Hosentasche hast.
Also durch Magnet einfach werden die nicht gemacht. Also ich denke, so Mikrowelle ist schon da ein adäquates Mittel. Wobei, wenn beim Schwimmerhand der Schlüssel mit dran ist, dann musst du ihn halt auch erst noch abmachen und weißt halt nicht, was da sonst noch an Metall ist. Du schleppst jetzt den Schwimmerhand auch nicht unbedingt eine Mikrowelle mit.
Aber ich meine, eine Batterie zum Beispiel, wenn es so möglich wäre, das unter Strom zu setzen oder so?
Nee, die sind ja komplett abgeschlossen. Also die sind ja wasserdicht auch und luftdicht im Prinzip. Du hast ja eine Chipkarte oder so einen kleinen Puck, so ein Ding, so ein Bubba, wo nichts ist. Das macht es ja so obskur, diese ganze Sache. Da ist einfach nichts, du siehst keine Kontakte, keine Anschlüsse, nichts ist einfach da.
Gut, aber ich kann sie ja auch auslesen. Es hieß ja auch, dass es zum Beispiel denkbar ist, dass die jetzt deaktiviert werden. Also wenn sie deaktiviert werden, dann werden sie ja auch irgendwie manipuliert.
Ja, das zweite, was ich versucht hatte rauszukriegen, vor allem bei dem einen Anrufer, der aus der Sicherheitsbranche kommt, ob die Dinger dann quasi unzerbringlich zerstört werden oder ob die ID, die auf dem Chip festgespeichert ist, nur lesegespeichert ist, zum Beispiel auf einer CD, lässt sich nicht mehr verändern, ob die dann im System deaktiviert wird. Das ist ja die Frage dabei. Und wenn es so ist, dann kannst du da auch gar nicht viel machen. Außer jetzt eine andere ID. Aber das geht ja nicht, weil die ist nicht veränderbar im Idealfall. Also wäre zumindest blöd Quatsch, wenn sie da eine veränderbare ID reinbringen würden. Es gibt ja auch unterschiedliche Smartkarten oder unterschiedliche Chipkarten. Es gibt solche, die nur Lesen sind, die also wirklich nur eine ID gespeichert haben. Oder es gibt welche, wo du auch Sachen speichern kannst, wo du auch Daten ablegen kannst, teilweise sogar umfangreich Daten ablegen kannst. Und dann solche, die auch selbst eine CPU haben, die richtig einen kleinen Computer eingebaut haben.
Das ist natürlich die Frage, wie das zum Beispiel im Schwimmbad funktioniert. Ob es so ist, dass du da einen Schlüssel abgibst und die speichern in ihrem System die Daten darüber, dass du dir eine Pommes damit gekauft hast oder wird das auf dem Schlüssel gespeichert?
Richtig, genau.
Weil sonst die Daten sind ja auf jeden Fall da. Und dann gucken die einfach, welcher Schlüssel, also selbst wenn das Ding im Arsch ist und keiner kann mehr sehen, was es für ein Schlüssel ist, dann gucken die einfach im System, welche Schlüssel sind draußen und welcher ist deiner. Dann musst du wahrscheinlich bis zum Ende des Tages warten.
In einer nassen Zelle.
Wie ist denn das, wenn jetzt eine Firma zum Beispiel so ein System einführen möchte und da unsicher ist? Was würdest du denn als Datenschützer jetzt den Leuten, den Firmen raten? Ist es jetzt sinnvoller, die Sachen, Chips mit so einer ID rauszugeben und dann alles in einer Datenbank zu halten? Oder ist es aus ethischen, aus moralischen Gründen dem Kundenschutz besser, die Sachen auf dem Chip zu speichern? Kann man da pauschal was sagen?
Also ich würde immer sagen, ethisch und moralisch ist schön, aber es geht hier auch knallhart einfach um rechtliche Fragen. Und da wäre es für das Unternehmen interessant zu bedenken, dass solche Anwendungen wie RFID-Tags aus datenschutzrechtlichen Gesichtspunkten einem einfach als Produkt um die Ohren fliegen können. Dass es da so ein erhebliches Risiko gibt, dass es irgendwann einfach den Verbraucher-Protest gibt, der es einem im Grunde nicht mehr erlaubt, mit diesen Sachen Business zu machen. Und da sollte man sich vorher absichern und sollte man mit Fachleuten entsprechend für Datensicherheit und Datenschutz sorgen. Und da ist der erste Schritt, die erste Frage eigentlich Datenvermeidung. Also zu vermeiden, dass überhaupt personenbezogen Daten irgendwo gespeichert werden bei der Nutzung dieser Tags. Wenn das nicht zu vermeiden ist oder man das eben nicht vermeiden will, wie es meistens der Fall ist, dann muss man dafür sorgen, dass die Kontrolle durch den einzelnen User möglichst hoch bleibt. Und diese Kontrolle liegt eigentlich in einer Anwendung, bei der ich selbst quasi die Herrschaftsgewalt über diese gespeicherten Daten behalte. Also auf der Chipkarte etwa, die ich habe, allein dort sind die Daten gespeichert und nicht zentralisiert in einem System, auf das ich selber überhaupt keinen Zugriff mehr habe. Also da wäre schon wahrscheinlich eine deutliche Trennung zu machen. Aber dann wiederum müsste die Datensicherheit dieses Chips so groß sein, dass nicht jeder X-Beliebige, der vorbeiläuft, diese Chips auslesen kann und mich damit verletzbar macht im Grunde.
Also mich würde das in erster Linie, wenn ich jetzt weiß, z.B.
Ich glaube, das ist auch der Grund, warum Walmart das zurückgezogen hat. Also offiziell haben wir da irgendwie beim Klicken keine wirkliche Begründung gefunden. Aber sie haben jetzt gesagt, dass sie dieses RFID-System, die waren eine der ersten, die das getestet haben, gesagt, naja, wir finden es ganz prima, dass wir das jetzt irgendwie für unsere interne Logistik einsetzen können und haben damit quasi stillschweigend wieder diesen Feldversuch beendet und machen das jetzt nicht mehr komplett für alle Artikel, sondern ich weiß nicht, ob es da jetzt wirklich massive Proteste gab. Also es gab Proteste auf jeden Fall, es gab Organisationen, die sich dagegen gewehrt haben, die da protestiert haben. Möglicherweise hat Walmart da auch erkannt, dass es, naja, bei den Kunden nicht ganz so gut ankommt. Möglicherweise, wenn da jemand mehr weiß, anrufen.
0331 77 97 110, wenn ihr mitdiskutieren möchtet beim Chaosradio auf Fretz. Am Telefon ist der Wolfgang aus Regensburg. Hallo Wolfgang.
Wie ist das Wetter in Berlin?
Na ja, es wird morgen gewittert und wir freuen uns alle drauf bei 27 Grad, schwül.
27.
Ja, jetzt ist aber gerade noch schön. Du kommst in einer guten Phase.
Ja, es ist ein schwieriges Thema, würde ich sagen, oder?
Ja, also wir sind baff, obwohl wir wussten, dass wir es machen.
Ehrlich, ja? Ja, nein, also ich bin erstmal grundsätzlich dagegen. Also man muss schon noch ein bisschen die Privatsphäre retten, würde ich sagen. Also jeder Mensch hat ja noch das Recht, irgendwo hinzugehen, ohne dass er überall beobachtet wird, oder? Ja, klar. Das ist doch, sag ich mal, das ist doch der Grundfakt, oder, als Mensch? Als Privatperson.
Natürlich.
Und daher ist halt die Frage, ob man das überhaupt weiter fördern soll, auch als Steuerzahler etc. oder? Man macht das ja automatisch.
Also ich finde es eher spannend, die Frage, was kann ich denn dagegen tun, wenn irgendwo so ein System eingeführt wird? Habe ich irgendwelche Möglichkeiten, was kann ich machen dagegen? Kann ich da protestieren, klagen, die Öffentlichkeit aufhetzen, das System zerstören, beschädigen, stören, wie auch immer? Also wie kann ich mich eigentlich dagegen wehren? Oder vor allem, was auch noch viel wichtiger ist, wie kann ich eigentlich meinen Bekannten, meinem Freundeskreis vermitteln, was dieses Problem einfach ist? Also wir als Chaos Computer Club sehen uns ständig mit der Problematik konfrontiert, dass wir einfach den Leuten gar nicht vermitteln können, wo unser Problem ist, wo wir die Gefahren sehen.
Es ist ja meistens so, dass wir eigentlich gar nicht wissen, wo dieses System schon vorherrscht, dass wir meistens in irgendein Geschäft oder in irgendeine öffentliche Einrichtung gehen und überhaupt nicht im Klaren sind, dass wir vielleicht schon die ganze Zeit beobachtet werden. Das ist ja nicht unbedingt eine Gefahr, aber man wird so automatisch wirklich als potenzieller Terrorist oder als potenzieller Klauer gleich irgendwie ausgemacht. Ich weiß nicht, das ist doch irgendwie schon beunruhigend.
Ja, die bloße Unsicherheit im Grunde genommen war auch ein Abstumpfungsinstrument. Dass man letztlich dann eben doch nicht genau wissen kann, ob jemand mit offenen Karten, mit offenem Visier spielt, wenn er mich im Supermarkt begrüßt und da Daten abgreift. Diese Unsicherheit ist etwas, was wir quasi tagtäglich in Kauf nehmen in irgendeiner Form. Und ich denke, die prägt auch unsere Wahrnehmung auf Dauer. Und da sehe ich auch schon das Problem.
Andererseits, was ich da noch interessant finde, es prägt offensichtlich nicht genug, um diejenigen, die mit den Systemen arbeiten, die uns jeden Tag betreffen, so zu prägen, dass die darauf eingehen würden. Also zum Beispiel in Amerika steht ja auf jedem Scheiß immer drauf, Vorsicht, nicht verschlucken, die Katze nicht in die Mikrowelle packen, diese Nummern, um sich rechtlich dagegen abzusichern, weil es da bestimmte Präzedenzfälle in diesem Bereich gegeben hat. Wenn ich zu meinem Supermarkttypen, minimal oder was auch immer, wo ich hingehe, reichelt oder wo auch immer hin, all die, wenn ich da sagen würde, sag mal, was von den Daten, die ich euch gebe, bewahrt ihr eigentlich auf? Die wissen überhaupt nicht, was ich will. Die würden mir da noch gar keine Antwort geben. Die würden sagen, da muss ich jetzt den Geschäftsführer freuen. Dann sagt er, da müsste ich jetzt bei der Hauptfiliale anrufen. Also die haben die Gewöhnung auch gar nicht, dass die Leute Daten haben wollen, könnten über das, was sie an Daten hinterlassen, oder?
Also gerade, wo du es ansprichst, Amerika, ich war jetzt Wochen in Amerika geschäftlich und das ist also die Leid da drüben übertreibend vollkommen. Also das kann man überhaupt nicht mit Deutschland vergleichen. Man steht in Amerika unter vollkommener Überwachung. Egal, wo man ist. Und es fängt an am Flughafen und endet dann im Hotel. Also das ist wirklich, da ist Deutschland und wirklich ein Witz dagegen.
Naja, wobei, wenn du mal richtig schlechte Laune kriegen willst, dann empfehle ich dir den Grundrechte-Report, der jedes Jahr von der humanistischen Union auch rausgegeben wird. Wird auch gehandelt als der alternative Verfassungsschutzbericht. Und den kann ich dir empfehlen. Da ist jetzt glaube ich im aktuellen nicht so furchtbar viel Überwachung drin. Aber schon, auch ja. Ich habe nur mal überflogen gerade. Ich habe mich mal ganz kurz durchgeblättert. Aber halt viel, was da einfach passiert, was die Dienste machen, was Polizei macht und sowas, war jedem ans Herz gelegt, der mal irgendwie gerade schlechte Laune haben will.
Erschienen bei RoVolt und nicht bei irgendeinem Freak-Verlag, okay?
Wenn ich mir will sagen, es ist wirklich so schlimm. Ich habe es halt in Amerika gemerkt, dass du wirklich überall Überwachungskameras hast, egal wo du hinkommst, selbst im Hotel wirklich überall. Und sag ich mal, was ich hier in Bayern, wenn man jetzt in einer Großstadt wie München oder in Nürnberg ist, nicht so hat. Also da kann ich halt doch wirklich noch in die U-Bahn einsteigen, ohne groß überwacht zu werden, habe ich das Gefühl.
Hast du das Gefühl?
Ja, eben, das ist es halt. Man hat viel, aber man weiß es halt nicht.
Das ist das Problem, das ich mit Deutschland habe und auch mit dem Bundesnachrichtendienst. Die stehen alle so deppert da, dass man eigentlich sagen würde, hier ist es noch nicht so schlimm, aber vielleicht ist das ja auch nur Fassade.
Also ich denke gerade bei dieser RFID-Geschichte, auch was jetzt die Registrierung von Einkaufen im Supermarkt geht, was das Ticket für den öffentlichen Nahverkehr angeht, das U-Bahn, S-Bahn-Ticket, das ist das, was die Firmen, die Unternehmen damit machen, ist ja noch die andere Sache. Aber die Sachen sind ja da, die Daten sind in der Datenbank, sie werden möglicherweise auch lange aufbewahrt. Und dann entstehen da natürlich auch Begehrlichkeiten dabei. Das heißt Begehrlichkeiten von Seiten des Staates, von den Ermittlungsbehörden, Polizei, Geheimdienste, da dann vielleicht möglicherweise auch mal so ein paar Daten zu kriegen. Also gerade so eine S-Bahn, dass dann auch irgendwie die Polizei mal hingeht, hier in Berlin, zu BVG zum Beispiel, und sagen ja, wir hätten hier den Herrn Müller, den würden wir gerne mal irgendwie, wo ist denn der gerade? Und dann gucken die ihre Datenbank und ja, der ist jetzt hier gerade irgendwie in die U-Bahn, in die Neue eingestiegen und so. Aber sie müssen sich beeilen, der ist heute ein bisschen später dran als sonst immer. Das ist halt da so ein denkbares Szenario dabei.
Ja, weil das ist ja dann wirklich schon 1984, also das wäre ja Irrsinn. Das kann man ja nicht machen mit den Leuten. Also ich weiß nicht, da traut man sich ja dann irgendwann bald nicht mehr auf die Straße zu gehen, weil man schon Angst hat, dass man in irgendwas verwickelt wird, nach dem Motto, dass man irgendjemanden guten Tag sagt, der halt verfolgt wird.
Das ist ganz witzig mit der Parallele 1984, dass du das nennst. Ich weiß, dass wir in der Schule immer beide Bücher gelesen haben. Wir haben George Orwell lesen müssen und wir haben aber auch lesen müssen Aldous Huxley, Schöne neue Welt. Und bei Schöner neuer Welt, da geht es eben um die Bequemlichkeit, da geht es um die sanfte Überwältigung. Also dieses wabernde Umfasstsein und Kontrolliertsein, ohne dass ich es eigentlich mitbekomme, spüre, was gerade sich verändert in der Umwelt. Und ich glaube, wir laufen eigentlich in so eine Art Zwischending zwischen diesen beiden Visionen, Utopien hinein. Und es ist interessant, dass du, Wolfgang, da eben die USA genannt hast. Ich glaube, ganz viele Trends kommen eben doch zurzeit aus der USA. Und wir können es nicht stoppen. Wir leben in einer globalisierten Welt. Und wenn die USA Standards setzen, auch in dem Bereich der Überwachung, dann müssen wir irgendwann nachziehen.
Siehe Sie Passagierdaten, Flugdatenaffäre?
Genau. Heute, wenn du in die USA fliegst, dann wissen die US-Behörden genau, ob du Vegetarier bist oder nicht.
Jetzt werden wirklich alle Daten weitergegeben. Das hab ich mir vorher auch noch sagen lassen. Man sollte im Flugzeug zum Beispiel kein Schweinefleisch ablehnen, wenn man sofort als essentieller Terrorist einlebt.
Dann dauert die Einreise eine Stunde länger.
Das ist jetzt ein Joke, oder?
Nein, ohne Mist.
Ist wirklich so, ohne Schmarrn.
Das hat die Kommission entschieden in Brüssel.
Es wurde vorher noch gesagt, wenn man im Flugzeug Schweinefleisch als Gericht ablehnt, dann wird das der amerikanischen Behörde gesagt. Die nehmen einen gleich als potentiellen Terrorist, als Mosle.
Du willst da echt nicht hin im Moment.
Es ist schon lustig, es macht fun, weil man gerade als Ausländer in Amerika sehr komisch behandelt wird. In Amerika ist man ja eigentlich gewohnt, dass überall Aircondition, also Klimaanlage ist. Aber gerade in der Ankunftshalle, in den Flughafen, wo man dann als Europäer einreist und drei Stunden in der Warteschlange warten darf, für den Personal-Check, wo man dann wirklich bis auf die Unterhose ausgenommen wird, dann natürlich keine Aircondition gibt. Bloß das ist jetzt nur am Rande.
Damit du schwitzt und damit die Handschuhe ein bisschen besser gleiten.
Ja, sicher. Wenn du aus dem Bereich wieder draußen bist, hast du natürlich wieder Klima. Es ist wirklich auch die ganze Kontrolle dann da. Du musst wirklich alles vorlegen, wie lange du bleibst, welches Hotel, wen du besuchst, die Nummern. Die wollen alles wissen.
Die nehmen ihr 11. September Trauma mit Freunden mit auf die nächsten 30 Jahre. Für all diejenigen, die sich über solche Fakten freuen, übrigens ist gerade wieder die RIA, ich weiß nicht, wer die Kommission kennt, das ist die Plattenindustrie, der Vorsitz der Plattenindustrie in Amerika, was bei uns die IFP ist. Die RIA hat jetzt einen neuen Chef und der ist natürlich Republikaner. Wie soll das auch sein? Gut, aber kommen wir zurück zum Thema. Vielen Dank für deinen Anruf erstmal. Was könnte sich die Regierung da alles wünschen? Das ist natürlich eine gute Frage. Gibt es denn da schon Erkenntnisse darüber, wo die überall drin hängt oder ist das alles noch grau in grau?
Also da wir jetzt nicht mal genau wissen, wo überhaupt in Deutschland zur Zeit diese RFID-Tags in der Anwendung sind, außer eben den Andeutungen, die wir heute durch ein paar interessante Anrufer eben bekommen haben.
Oh ja, Moment, E-Mail-Adresse, für den Fall, dass du jetzt schreiben kannst. 84.at.chaosradio.ccc.de ist unsere E-Mail-Adresse. Wir würden uns natürlich über eine Mail freuen, die vielleicht detaillierte Pläne, nicht? Also 84.at.chaosradio.ccc.de und die gilt natürlich nicht nur für Informanten, die sprachwillig sind, sondern auch für alle, die noch Fragen haben, was diese Sendung anbelangt.
Ja, also genaueres wissen wir nicht, aber was man sicherlich sagen kann nach der Erfahrung von 30 Jahren, einfach Beobachtung des Staates und was seine Überwachungspraktiken angeht, ist, dass in der Regel die Behörden dort mit am Tisch sitzen, wo es für sie auch interessant sein könnte. Da sitzen dann zum Beispiel in Entwicklergremien in bestimmten großen Firmen sitzen plötzlich irgendwelche Herren im Anzug, die nicht namentlich vorgestellt werden und hören da sehr genau zu. Und da geht es dann darum, zum Beispiel in bestimmten einzelnen Anwendungen, da könnte ich mir zum Beispiel das Ticket-System vorstellen, bei bestimmten Anwendungen eben möglicherweise eine Schnittstellenzugang zu bestimmten Datenbanken zu erhalten und dann Zugriffsmöglichkeiten für Sicherheitsbehörden eben zu erlangen. Wie gesagt, das kann ja nicht bei allen Anwendungen der Fall sein. Wir haben ja heute auch interessante und wahrscheinlich auch nette, bequeme Anwendungen gehört, aus der privaten Wirtschaft, die uns vielleicht das Leben erleichtern. Aber bei bestimmten zentralen Infrastrukturen, Alltagsinfrastrukturen, da bin ich mir sicher, da sitzt dann auch einer mit von staatlicher Seite und hört mit und möchte da den Zugriff, ganz klar.
Wie zum Beispiel auch bei der Lkw-Maut, die jetzt irgendwie eingeführt wird, die möglicherweise auch irgendwann für PKWs kommt und dann gibt es wirklich auch die totale Kontrolle und da wären auch die feuchtesten Träume der Behörden dann wahr.
Die feuchten Träume der Behörden. Wenn ihr euch solche auch ausmalen könnt in euren Köpfen, Berliner und Brandenburger, dann ruft an 0371 77 97 110 beim Chaosradio heute Abend und der Florian auch aus Regensburg, ist eine Regensburg-Offensive jetzt gerade hier, ist am Telefon. Hallo Florian. Dein Vorredner war auch aus Regensburg.
Dein Vorredner war auch aus Regensburg.
Ja, zu dem wollte ich auch noch mal kurz was sagen. Er sagte nämlich, dass in den U-Bahnen in München nicht Video überwacht wird. Ich glaube nämlich, dass der liebe Herren noch nicht Bus gefahren ist bei uns in Regensburg. Denn bereits in den Bussen wird Video überwacht. Also wenn ich in der Früh zur Schule fahre, muss ich bereits auf den Scheiben einen Aufkleber lesen mit diese Bus wird Video überwacht. Natürlich aus hygienischen Gründen. Vielleicht kann man das auch in gewisser Weise verstehen, wenn die Jugendlichen dort hinten immer alles vollschmieren. Aber wollte ich also noch mal kurz mit meinem Vorredner sagen.
Das heißt, die U-Bahnen werden nicht überwacht, aber die Busse?
Aber Florian, bei euch wird ja auch die Innenstadt überwacht, ne?
Ja, wir sind ja auch das Pilotprojekt da.
Und zwar sind das die alten Kameras eben auch der Stadtwerke, wenn ich das richtig gehört hab. Und da hat einfach die Polizei gesagt, die sind ja ganz prima, die hängen ja schon. Und da wollen wir jetzt auch mal zugreifen. Und das ist natürlich auch spektakulär aus datenschutzrechtlicher Sicht, weil eigentlich heißt es ja immer, nur an kriminellen Brennpunkten sozusagen dürfen diese Kameras überhaupt hängen. Und da hat man einfach mal pauschal gesagt, überall wo die BVG guckt, da muss auch unbedingt der Staat mitgucken.
Das ist ja auch überall kriminell. Die ganzen Schwarzfahrer, die müssen wir jetzt auch mal alles, sind ja alles Kriminelle. Das ist ein Schwerpunkt, krimineller Brennpunkt, so gesehen.
Ich hab dann auch schon mal eine E-Mail geschickt, also den der Polizeistation hier in Regensburg. Und hab sie also mal gefragt, was die Argumente denn dafür wären. Und hab also wirklich bloß so einen Standardbrief zurückbekommen, dass ich mich doch bitte in der Homepage informieren sollte. Und das war's also. Richtig Informationen dazu hab ich also auch nicht wirklich bekommen. Aber ich wollt noch was zu diesen kontaktlosen Chipkarten sagen. Ich hab in der Universität in Regensburg mal praktiziert. Und bin dort, also hab dort als allererstes gleich drei, vier Chipkarten in die Hände bekommen. Darunter auch so eine kontaktlose Chipkarte für diese Mensa. Und hab darauf auch mal irgendwie Studenten angesprochen, ob die sich darüber schon mal in Datenschutz-Hinsicht da schon mal informiert haben. Und ob die da irgendwie keine Angst darüber haben, ob das bald nicht in jedem Supermarkt vorhanden ist. Aber bin da also auch ebenfalls nur auf Ignoranz gestoßen und hab nur komische Blicke riskiert, also bekommen sozusagen. War auch recht übel und hat mir auch etwas Angst gemacht, muss man sagen.
Ja, also dieses Bewusstsein für dieses zentrale Grundrecht eigentlich, wie das Bundesverfassungsgericht das mal so schön gesagt hat, das droht dann noch ein bisschen unterzugehen, einfach in der Fülle der Anwendungen, die es heute eben möglich machen, einfach Daten abzuspeichern und zu nehmen.
Aber ist das noch selbstverschuldete Unmündigkeit, wenn ich solche Sachen nicht in Anspruch nehme? Das ist nämlich so eine Grundfrage, weil kann ich überhaupt noch sicher wissen, wie ich einem Polizisten gegenüber trete? Was darf so ein Polizist? Was darf der von mir fordern? Was darf der sagen? Was darf der nicht sagen? Was darf der annehmen? Was darf der mir gegenüber aussprechen? Und was darf bei Sachen, die um mich herum passieren, überhaupt passieren? Die meisten Leute sind doch sofort eingeschüchtert, wenn irgendjemand sagt, ja, bitte mir den Ausweis sehen. Das passiert ja, wenn da ein Betrugener vor dir steht, der das mal als Gag probiert hat.
Wär mal ein cooles Schulfach.
Auf jeden Fall. So was wie Staatsbürgerkunde, im Grunde.
Wir können auch niemandem einen Vorwurf dafür machen, dass er da nicht überall durchsteigt und dass letztlich nicht alles selber mehr durchblickt. Das ist auch viel zu kompliziert geworden, wo eben da und herum werden, wo nicht. Aber dann müssen wir auch politisch dafür sorgen, dass Strukturen da sind, die sich um diese Geschichten kümmern, dass es eben entsprechende Institutionen gibt, die sich kümmern, stellvertretend, auf die man sich dann auch verlassen kann, die eben entsprechend strukturierend Transparenz schaffen, die eben nachvollziehbar machen, was passiert um uns herum.
Wobei ich persönlich so ein bisschen den Eindruck hab, also gerade was hier auch den Berliner Datenschutzbeauftragten oder das Berliner Büro angeht, dass die sehr nur darauf achten, dass die Firmen, das Unternehmen mit den Daten nichts Böses anfangen, die nicht irgendwie missbrauchen. Aber ich habe immer das Gefühl, also auch was jetzt so bei der Geschichte um diese Lkw-Maut, die jetzt eingeführt wird, dass es da auch von Seiten der Datenschützer kaum Bedenken gibt, was jetzt die staatlichen Zugriffe angeht. Ich weiß nicht, Nils, wie ist da dein Eindruck? Kannst du das bestätigen? Ist da das Bewusstsein dafür da, dass der Staat auch mal böse Dinge tun könnte?
Auf jeden Fall. Also es gibt eine Tradition, auch gerade bei den Datenschützern, da muss ich doch jetzt mal eine Lanze brechen, zum Beispiel für die schleswig-holsteinischen Datenschützer und Herrn Bäumler und Herrn Weichert, die dort führend immer so die Trommel rühren und kräftig auch schlagen gegen staatliche Überwachungsmaßnahmen. Also es gibt da eine ganze Reihe von sehr exponierten Datenschützern, ganz klar. Aber es gibt auch Bundesländer, wo eben entsprechend so eine Art politischer Schlingerkurs gefahren wird und man sich eben mit dem Backstein nicht unbedingt anlegen will und es mit ihm nicht verscherzen will oder wie auch immer. Und da eben die Unabhängigkeit der Behörde dann manchmal auch in Rede steht. Und umso wichtiger ist es dann, dass es Bürgerrechtsgruppen gibt und Bürgerrechtsvereinigungen gibt, die ganz unabhängig und ohne andere Interessen da eben die Trommel schlagen können und auf solche Sachen wie die LKW-Maut, die du genannt hast, hinweisen können.
Wem unterstehen die Datenschutzbeauftragte eigentlich? Sind die irgendjemand von irgendjemandem? Unterstehen die dem Ministerium? Oder sind die irgendwie in diese Systeme eingeordnet? Wo stehen die ungefähr?
Ja, das ist eben in jedem Bundesland anders geregelt. Aber in der Regel kannst du erstmal davon ausgehen, dass eben das Geld vom Staat kommt, um diese Behörden zu finanzieren. Und wenn da irgendwie die Politik nicht stimmt, dann gibt es natürlich immer auch den Haushaltshahn, an dem man drehen kann. Und das siehst du ja auch an der personellen Unterbesetzung dieser Behörden, dass sie meistens nicht die Kontrolle ausüben können, die sie eigentlich wollten.
Florian, wir haben dich nicht vergessen. Es war nur ein Exkurs und wir konnten dich nicht an uns halten.
Alles klar. Gut, dann werde ich heute bestimmt gut schlafen. Also danke, wiederhören.
So, damit sind wir mit den Regensbürgern aber auch durch. Und ja, großes Hallo.
Hallo, hier ist Fettes Brot.
Hi, ich bin Willi aus dem entgeilen Groß Rädchen. Und auch das entgeile Groß Rädchen wird es irgendwann erwischen. Wir haben noch eine gute halbe Stunde Zeit im Chaos Radio hier heute Abend. Nils ist im Studio von der Humanistischen Union. Der Frank vom Chaos Computer Club und meine Person Max von Fritz abgestellt für den heutigen Abend, letzter Mittwoch im Monat. Deswegen wird über, naja, MultimediaList darf man ruhig mal sagen, ist ja ein Unwort, aber über MultimediaList diskutiert und in diesem Fall über diese kleinen wunderbaren Funkchips, die uns in den nächsten zwei Jahren wahrscheinlich marktreif beglücken werden und ja nach Aussage von Anrufern heute Abend schon mannigfaltig installiert sind und existieren. Und zwar schon seit Jahren. Wenn ihr darüber noch Informationen habt, dann ruft einfach an 0331 77 97 110 oder auch nur, wenn ihr das Thema kommentieren möchtet. Am Telefon ist der, wendet, jetzt muss ich mich mal eben orientieren, Michael aus Berlin mal wieder, Hallo Michael, Michael, ja sorry, ihr müsst manchmal länger warten, das tut uns leid, aber das Thema ist natürlich auch sehr spannend. Katharina, hallo, Katharina?
Ja, hallo, ich hab schon gedacht, das sei eine reine Jungensendung, nachdem seit ungefähr zwei Stunden keine Frau mehr bei euch angerufen hat.
Dabei hat es nicht mal so direkt mit Computern zu tun wie sonst immer hier.
Naja, aber es ist ja vielleicht doch einigermaßen typisch, dass nur so ein paar, also jetzt so zugespitzt gesprochen, Technikfreaks sich für das Thema interessieren und das wahrscheinlich die breite Masse der Bevölkerung relativ kalt lässt.
Wir haben unsere Limits erfüllt, denn direkt als zweiter Anrufer war eine Anruferin und damit haben wir hier unser kleines Kreuzchen gemacht in dem Feld Anruferin und damit ist das für uns erledigt. Du bist schon über die Statistik hinaus, du wirst für die nächste Sendung schon gewertet.
Ah ja, interessant ist, ne, aber es ist ein bisschen typisch auch oder passt ganz gut in meine Beobachtung zu dem Thema. Im Grunde kommt es mir so vor, als würden wir zu completen unserer eigenen Überwachung hier, weil wir so bequem sind und es ist ja auch alles ganz wunderbar, wenn man irgendwie an der Kasse nicht mehr warten muss, sondern einfach durchgehen kann oder am Skilift einfach durchgehen kann und das alles irgendwie elektronisch berechnet und dann wahrscheinlich noch automatisch vom Konto abgebucht wird. Und ich glaube, es ist unheimlich schwer, Rechte zu verteidigen, wo es uns im Grunde überhaupt nicht wehtut, die aufzugeben. Und deshalb frage ich mich, wie kann man überhaupt Menschen dafür sensibilisieren, was da passiert und wie da in ihre Privatsphäre eingegriffen wird und irgendwie effektives politisches Handeln erreichen, wenn das doch im Grunde kein Recht ist, um das Menschen irgendwie bereit sind zu kämpfen, weil sie merken, dass ihnen was fehlt, wenn ihnen immer mehr die Versorgung über ihre Daten entzogen wird.
Wie war das, die Leute kämpfen jetzt für Hunde und Benzin?
Ja und wir von dem Bürgerrecht, wir sagen, über Spitze ausgedrückt, uns fehlen einfach die Robbenbabys sozusagen, die mit so großen Kulleraugen immer entsprechend an uns schauen und die Herzen hängen. Also das ist wirklich, dieses Moment fehlt. Und dann ist natürlich die Frage, inwiefern ist es eigentlich legitim, immer mehr Angst zu machen eigentlich und eine Angst zu schüren, die möglicherweise auch nicht gerechtfertigt ist. Weil einfach zum Beispiel bestimmte Sachen technisch noch nicht so entwickelt sind, nicht so ausgereift sind, wie eben die wütendsten Visionen das immer schildern. Das ist eine ganz schwierige Frage.
Andererseits hat es mir das schon zu denken gegeben, was hier so von den anderen Hörern erzählt wurde, wo es überall diese AF-Techs schon gibt. Das ist ja im Grunde erheblich weiter verbreitet, als das jemals in der Presse auch berichtet wurde, so wie ich das mitgekriegt habe.
Ja, und das ist aber eine Frechheit, ehrlich gesagt. Weil wenn diese Geschichte tatsächlich gekoppelt wird mit anderen Technologien, zum Beispiel mit der Videoüberwachung und da tatsächlich personenbezogene Daten automatisch erhoben werden, dann handelt es sich hier einfach auch eine heimliche Form der Datenverarbeitung gegenüber den Kunden, die eigentlich einen ganz klaren Rechtsverstoß bedeutet und diese Unternehmen auch schadensersatzpflichtig macht aus einem Verstoß gegen das Persönlichkeitsrecht dieser einzelnen Verbraucher. Und da kann man nur einfach alle aufrufen, die an diesem Thema interessiert sind, dann auch mal einfach gezielt ihr Auskunftsrecht zu nutzen und dahin zu gehen, zu so einem Laden, den man da vermutet, mit solchen Technologien und die einfach mal zu aufzufordern, ihnen zu sagen, was sie für Technologien da nutzen und einfach diese Transparenz einzufordern.
Ja, und gibt es denn auch irgendwie, also du bist ja glaube ich auch von einer Bürgerrechtsorganisation, gibt es denn auch Organisationen, die sich da drum kümmern, damit ich nicht irgendwie als einzelne kleine Blöde dann zu so einem Laden laufen muss? Und das habt ihr ja auch vorhin schon beschrieben, was dann wahrscheinlich passiert ist. Der Verkäufer sagt, kenne ich mich nicht mit aus, und fragen Sie den Geschäftsführer und schreiben Sie einen Brief, und das dauert dann alles ewig und führt zu nichts. Also kann man das mit ein bisschen mehr Druck machen? Macht ihr da was, oder macht der Chaos Computer Club da irgendwas?
Also erstmal würde ich auf jeden Fall hier zum Beispiel in Berlin die Berliner Datenschutzbehörde auf den Port setzen. Die sind natürlich auch zuständig, wenn es solche Verdachtsfälle gibt in Unternehmen, da auch eine Ermittlung anzustellen. Ein Beispiel kann ich nennen in dem Bereich der Videoüberwachung. Da ist ja zum Beispiel jetzt das Kulturkaufhaus wegen seiner Bürgersteigüberwachung vor Gericht gezerrt worden von einem Journalisten. Das ist ein Beispiel, wo die Bürgerrechtler mit die Trommel gerührt haben, damit da eine Aufmerksamkeit für diese Geschichte entsteht. Und dann ist die Datenschutzbehörde mit hinzugekommen und hat gesagt, ja das ist in der Tat ein Fall auch für uns und ermittelt und untersucht diesen Fall auch mittlerweile. Also erstmal aber die Zuständigen sollte man informieren und dann davon unabhängig aber auch natürlich überlegen, ob man nicht über solche Gruppen, Bürgerrechtsgruppen, wie sie zum Beispiel im Haus der Demokratie und Menschenrechte sitzen hier in Berlin, auch mal eine Kampagne zu starten und im Einzelfall auf solche Sachen hinzuweisen.
Der CCC ist jetzt tendenziell bei diesen Sachen eher von der technischen Seite an. Das heißt, um dann auch für solche Sachen mir einen technischen Background zu geben.
Wie kann man es hacken?
Wie kann man es hacken? Wie funktioniert das? Es ist aus technischer Sicht jetzt irgendwie diese Sorge begründet oder unbegründet. Oder welche Möglichkeiten bestehen aus technischer Möglichkeit, von den technischen Möglichkeiten noch? Das ist also jetzt eher unser Bereich, wie wir da rangehen würden. Wir sind halt alle keine Juristen. Wir kommen ja aus der technischen Ecke und haben jetzt neben dem Spaß am Gerät, sag ich mal, mit diesen Sachen rumzuspielen, die vielleicht auch kreativ zu nutzen für irgendwelche Aktionen, um tatsächlich auch mit einer gezielten Aktion auf sowas aufmerksam zu machen. Das ist wahrscheinlich eher so unser Bereich. Aber deswegen machen wir auch gerade mal die Sendung zusammen, weil wir glauben, dass sich das unheimlich gut ergänzt.
Die beiden haben sich jetzt ausgesprochen. Katharina.
Ja, und ich habe viel Neues erfahren.
Schön. Freut uns.
Ja, vielen Dank für den Anruf.
Vielen Dank für die spannende Sendung.
So, bevor wir nachher wieder Ärger kriegen, weil ich natürlich weiß, dass die Hackordnung innerhalb des Chaos Computer Clubs immer zu großen Wunden führt, wenn diese Sendung vorbei ist, gebe ich dir jetzt noch mal die Chance, Frank, vor den Nachrichten bekannt zu geben, dass es das Chaos Camp gibt.
Es gibt das Camp, genau. Und zwar, es findet statt nächstes Wochenende. Nicht dieses Wochenende, sondern in 10 Tagen, sozusagen vom 8. bis zum 10. August in Alt Landsberg. Und wir brauchen dafür morgen auch vielleicht noch ein paar Aufbauhelfer. Am besten klickt ihr mal auf www.ccc.de slash camp slash 2003. Und da gibt es alles notwendige an Infos. Und wir werden auf jeden Fall vier Tage richtig viel Spaß haben. Es gibt Internet, bringt eure Zelte mit, eure Computer, eure Freunde. Und alles wird gut.
Wir haben dran gedacht, ja, ja. Das Wetter abends und nachts ziehen so ein paar Wolken durch bei 17 bis 13 Grad. Tags scheint erst mal die Sonne. Später gibt es dann vereinzelt Schauer oder Gewitter bei maximal 27 bis 30 Grad. Jetzt die Meldung mit Matthias Kerkov.
Bei der umstrittenen Arbeitszeit Verlierer haben sich der Berliner Senat und die Gewerkschaften noch nicht geeinigt. Das sagte der regierende Bürgermeister Woverheit nach rund vier stündigen Verhandlungen. Woverheit stellte klar, dass der Senat die Erhöhung der Pflichtstundenzahl für Angestelltelehrer nicht zurücknehmen wird. Der PDS-Vorsitzende Bisky hat die Stasi-Unterlagenbehörde kritisiert. Sie sei mit aufgetauchten, aufgetauchten über neue Aktien. Da fehlen ein paar Worte irgendwie. Dann sagen wir mal, sie sei mit aufgetauchten Fakten oder so nicht fair umgegangen. Er sei ungleich behandelt worden, weil Journalisten neues Material bei seiner Person früher als er bekommen hätten, sagte Bisky im RBW Brandenburg. Das Klinikum Frankfurt Oder will Anzeige gegen Unbekannt erstatten. Bei dem Einbau der Wasserleitungen seien schwere Fehler gemacht worden, sagte der zuständige Vorstand des Klinikträgers der Bild-Zeitung. Das Klinikum trage für die Todesfälle keine Verantwortung. In dem Krankenhaus waren zwei Menschen an der seltenen Degionärskrankheit gestorben. Und noch zum Sport. Fußball-Bundesligist Wolfsburg steht so gut wie sicher in einem Finale des UEI Cups. Im Halbfinale-Hinspiel siegten die Wolfsburger gegen Prazien mit 4 zu 1. Und die Verkehrsredaktion hat keine Meldungen. Wutte Fahrt.
Heute Abend.
Film-Bluemoon-Spezial.
Mit MC-Lücke.
Der Fritz-Film-Bluemoon live aus dem Kubiksuferpalast Alexanderplatz. Wie immer mit Fritz-Filmexperte Ronald Blum und einem einzigen Thema. Terminator 3. Die Rückkehr des Terminators Anni ist back. Aber bringt er es noch als Terminator? Und wie wirken sich eigentlich Falten bei einer Maschine aus? Der Fritz-Film-Bluemoon live aus dem Kubiksuferpalast Alexanderplatz in der Rathorstraße 1 in Berlin-Mitte.
Der Film-Bluemoon-Spezial heute Abend ab 22 Uhr.
Hier hört das Chaos Radio auf, Fritz. 0 Uhr 40 haben wir es gleich, das heißt wir haben noch 20 Minuten Zeit. Thema heute Abend, ein Aufreger kann man schon so sagen. Wir haben Themen gehabt, wo nicht so große Resonanz vorhanden war, weil das ist etwas, was uns in allen Lebensbereichen, jeden in allen Lebensbereichen betreffen wird, wenn das so durchgesetzt wird, wie wir uns das hier so vorstellen. Denn es geht um diese kleinen Chips RFID, sind hier abgekürzt, das ist der Oberbegriff für das ganze Thema heute Abend. Ja Chips, die eigentlich überall draufgeklebt werden können, wenn sie klein sind, flexibel sind, nicht zu entdecken sind, auch nicht schlimmer sind als irgendwie ein Schildchen, was ihr hinten in eurem Pulli habt oder irgendwas, was auf eurer Butter klebt und diese Teile funken in Formationen. Dafür gibt es ganz, ganz viele Anwendungsbereiche, die wir jetzt nicht nochmal alle aufzählen wollen, denn die Diskussionen sind voll im Gange und ihr könnt unter 033 177 97 110 mitmachen und natürlich drüber philosophieren, ob das okay ist oder nicht. Im Studio natürlich vom Chaos Computer Club der Frank von der Humanistischen Union, weil wir brauchen heute Abend einen Rechtsanwalt und Bürgerrechtler, ist der Nils und meine Person der Max und am Telefon ist der Marco aus Ingolstadt, na schau.
Ich wollte das Chaos Radio erzählen und zwar bin ich selber in Kontakt mit den Karten jetzt gekommen. Ich habe auch selber eine und zwar arbeite ich jetzt für eine etwas größere Firma und da wird seit Jahren diese RFID schon benutzt für bargagloses Zahlen.
Wobei?
Das ist also jeder Getränkeautomat, jeder Zigarettenautomat, die ganzen Shops, wo man Essen kaufen kann und so, ist schon alle damit ausgestattet.
Das muss ja eine große Firma sein, wenn es da wie eine eigene Welt gibt oder so.
Und jetzt dieses Jahr ist es auch neu gekommen, dass die kompletten Karten, wo man praktisch gesehen, sich stempelt praktisch gesehen, wann man gekommen ist, dann Zugangskontrollen und und und, auch mit alles auf der gleichen Karte ist, wo man auch mit bezahlt. Das heißt praktisch gesehen sind da so ziemlich viel sämtliche Daten drauf gespeichert, die über den jeweiligen Benutzer eben vorhanden sind, die dann auch eben zum größten Teil mit übertragen werden, wenn man sich dann eben irgendwo einloggt, irgendwo durchgehen will, oder nur sagen will, dass man da ist.
Wird denn das, was du kaufst, automatisch von deinem Gehalt abgezogen, oder wie funktioniert das dann? Oder hast du da so eine Prepaid-Funktionalität?
Nein, das ist ein System, also der Chip ist von Legit Ident Systems, die sind schon ziemlich krass drauf. Und da hat so eine Firma DBS direkt solche Kassensysteme entwickelt, dass jede Karte, da ist ein Automat vorne dran, wo man sein Guthaben auf der Karte übersetzen kann und dann praktisch gesehen dieses eben abkassieren kann. Da ist jede einzelne Karte drauf gespeichert in so einem riesengroßen System und da hat jede Karte den Kontostand praktisch gesehen auf dem Server.
Das ist schon sehr sehr flexibel.
Die hat ihre ID, sagt hallo, ich bin Karte Nummer so und so und das selber gibt zurück, ah ja, du hast so und so viel Geld auf deinem Konto drauf.
Fett! Und was die Auswertung der Daten anbelangt oder was die Mitarbeiter so darüber wissen, was da für Daten gespeichert werden, wie weit ist das fortgeschritten?
Wissen tun die im Grunde, was ich bis jetzt mitgekriegt habe, nicht viel. Da kann eigentlich wirklich fast keiner was dazu sagen. Sie wissen bloß, ja, das ist jetzt neu gekommen und ist toll, weil mit den neuen Karten kann man sich halt, das ist ein riesengroßes Gelände, man kann halt zu jedem Eingang, also das sind ja hunderte von Eingängen so ungefähr auf das Gelände, man kann halt bei jedem Eingang sich praktisch gesehen einstempeln. Und mit den alten Karten, von denen hab ich zum Glück noch eine, wo halt dieses System noch nicht vorhanden ist, gibt es halt nur noch ein paar, wo man sich eben einloggen kann.
Wie heißen die Legend?
Ja, super, ist alles auf einer Karte, ich kann damit bezahlen, ich kann damit reingehen und kann mich damit einstempeln. Und das ist halt im Grunde dieser Gedankensatz, die meisten Mitarbeiter, die ich jetzt hier mitgekriegt habe, haben.
Wie heißen die Legend? Wie Legende.
Und da ist dann auch schon eine riesengroße Liste, wenn man unter References geht. Und da sieht man also schon, wir sind weltweit schon eingesetzt, teilweise auch schon für bargeldlose Zahlen, Access-Control, für Hotels und...
Ja, Access-Control, Ticketing, Hotel, Payment, Parking, POS, Road Tall. Ja, schöne Liste. Danke, gleich mal notieren, die URL ist prima.
Ja, also die Chips, die finde ich auch schon ganz schön nett, sind aber noch ein bisschen teuer, so Stationen und sowas auszulesen. Die Beschlüsselung ist, habe ich auch schon was gefunden, ist also so eine Eigenproduktion von denen, wo leider überhaupt noch nichts dokumentiert ist. Mal schauen, ob wir das irgendwie machen.
Und du arbeitest für Volkswagen, Daimler-Kreisler, die Deutsche Bank oder Siemens?
Für was genau, sage ich nicht.
Mein lieber Scholli, die haben nämlich das auch in der Regel fast alles. Ja, wieder mal beängstigen, danke schön.
Okay, vielen Dank für den Anruf, Marco.
Anrufer haben wir noch in der Leitung, wir haben noch ein bisschen Zeit zu talken. Moment, ganz kurz orientieren, der Sebastian aus Berlin ist am Telefon. Hallo Sebastian.
Hallo.
Ich finde die Aufregung nicht ganz so aufregend, wie ihr das empfindet, sondern ich nehme Bezug auf den Anrufer aus Regensburg. Ich reise sehr viel beruflich, bin in Hongkong, was weiß ich, Zürich, sonst wo, New York und dort wird zum Beispiel das öffentliche Nahverkehrssystem in Hongkong komplett überwacht. Zürich ist gerade in der Diskussion, alles Video zu überwachen, aufgrund von starken Vandalismus und hier in Berlin ist jedes Mal, wenn ich zurückkomme, die Aufregung ziemlich groß um kleine Themen eigentlich, weil wenn ich hier mit dem öffentlichen Nahverkehrssystem fahren will, störe ich mich erstmal als erstes weder über eine Videoüberwachung, sondern über bekleckerte Sitze, Vandalismus ohne Ende, dass Straftäter nicht irgendwo dingfest gemacht wird, es wird volkswirtschaftliche Güter werden zerstört und in Berlin gibt es immer diese müßige Diskussion um diese ganzen Sachen, dass Persönlichkeitsrechte eventuell beschädigt werden könnten. In London war der Fall, dass durch eine Videoüberwachung ein dramatischer Mord an einem kleinen Kind aufgedeckt werden konnte. Es waren zwei auch leider Kinder. Es ist mir keinen Fall bekannt geworden, dass irgendwie ein Mensch zu Schade gekommen ist, der also in London in der U-Bahn gelaufen ist und vielleicht sich ein Pornoheft gekauft hätte. Also beispielsweise, es geht ja um Persönlichkeitsrechte. Und diese Aufregung, die in Berlin, ich bin gebürtiger Berliner, jedes Mal herrscht, ist für mich wirklich absurd. Weil wir genauso das Thema mal begreifen können. In New York gab es Giuliano, der es geschafft hat, diese Stadt umzukehren. Dass Leute, die was wollten, eine Chance bekommen haben. Auch Leute, die sozial schwächer gestellt waren, eine Chance bekommen hatten, zu arbeiten. Oder wie auch immer. Jedenfalls es florierte wieder in den 90er Jahren. Und hier ist immer diese grüsige Diskussion, wir müssen jeden schützen. Persönlichkeitsrecht über alles.
Ich weiß nicht warum. Du siehst ja eine Menge der Anrufer, die da durchaus auch Bedenken haben. Dass es einfach unterschiedliche Interessen gibt. Und es gibt sicherlich dieses Interesse, auch zugunsten der Sicherheit Vorkehrungen zu treffen. Was ich nicht ganz sehe, ist dein englisches Beispiel. Du hast da diesen Mordfall, Jamie Bulger, eigentlich zitiert. Diese beiden Jungs, die da eben ein junges Kind aus dem Supermarkt, aus dem Einkaufszentrum mitgenommen haben. Das war nun eigentlich ein interessantes Beispiel, weil genau in dem Fall dieses Einkaufszentrum komplett Video überwacht war. Und diese Videos aber eben nicht verhindern konnten, dass dieses Kind umgebracht wurde. Das war also tatsächlich, da wurde live zugeschaut und nichts geschah. Und da kann man natürlich auch schon die Frage stellen, war nicht die Mutter dieses Kindes, fühlte sich in einer trügerischen Sicherheit und hat quasi mal nicht aufgepasst, weil sie dachte, hier ist eh alles überwacht. Und schwupps war dieses Kind weg. Also das ist ein sehr ambivalenter Fall, den du da geschildert hast. Und auch die Engländer fangen jetzt langsam an, die Ambivalenzen ihres Systems zu erkennen. Es gab zum Beispiel mal ein Outing in Edinburgh. Ein ungewolltes Outing in der Schwulenszene von Edinburgh. Da war es einfach über Videokameras rausgekommen, dass eine bestimmte Person eben zu dieser Szene gehört. Und dieses Videoband wurde veröffentlicht. Und dieses Outing hat einen dieser Angehörigen dieser Szene dann in den Selbstmord getrieben. Das wurde auch groß in den Medien berichtet. Also da gibt es auch schon erste Fragezeichen, ob da nicht ambivalente Wirkungen eintreten. Und ich denke, wir müssen schon auch sehen, dass es eben die deutsche Datenschutztradition gibt. Und es gibt hier ein bestimmtes Selbstverständnis von Persönlichkeitsrechten und von Grundrechten, was auch ein Stück, glaube ich, kulturelle Identität ist.
Na gut, also jetzt mal beschränkt auf öffentliche Nahverkehrsmittel. Würde ihr denn das höher stellen, zu sagen, ok, Persönlichkeitsrecht gegenüber dem zerstörerischen Wahn, der ja hier in Berlin offensichtlich ist, dass U-Bahnen und Busse zerstört werden, dass man gezielt sagt, ok, durch eine flächendeckende Überwachung können wir diesem Vandalismus eventuell, ich sage auch mit Absicht, eventuell Einhalt gebieten in Zürich. Die Schweiz ist ja nun mit allen Vor- und Nachteilen ein Land, wo sehr, sehr viel genau über diese Persönlichkeitsrechte diskutiert wird. Und jetzt wurde gerade in mehreren Abstimmungen und Volksabstimmungen, wie auch immer, eben gestattet, dass in Zürich jetzt erstmalig eine komplette Videoüberwachung stattfinden darf, aufgrund dieser schweren Zerstörung, die eben gezielt dieser Sache vorbeugen sollen. Also hier wäre doch die Frage, ist es wirklich so dramatisch zu sagen, hier wird ein fantastisches System zerstört von irgendwelchen Leuten, die also immer wieder wahrscheinlich in Erscheinung treten, Wiederholungstäter sind, ist das nicht höher zu stellen? Das ist ein höheres Gut, dass eine Stadt, eine Gemeinde, eine Gemeinschaft, ein Land sagt, wir wollen eigentlich hier ein System zur Verfügung stellen, was mit öffentlichen Geldern finanziert wird und wollen uns auch schützen vor Zerstörung.
Wäre es denn nicht besser, wenn wir uns erstmal Gedanken darüber machen, warum diese Leute das machen und vielleicht dagegen vorzugehen?
Nein, die Zeit ist ja nicht dazu da. Warum? Ich kann doch nicht jeden fragen, hast du Probleme mit der Schule, hast du Probleme mit den Eltern? Diese Diskussion, pardon, ich sage das auch ganz hart, gehört für mich in die 18er, 19er, nicht mehr in die 19er Jahre, in die 17er, 18er Jahre, das wird eine Entwicklung hier in dem Land. Aber das ist für mich vollkommen vorbei. Wer sich einem System zerstörerisch entgegenstellt, muss auch nicht erwarten, dass er behätschelt wird in meinen Augen.
Aber glaubst du nicht, dass es Gründe dafür gibt, auch warum die Leute das machen?
Ja natürlich, aber du kannst doch genauso fragen, es gibt genauso, ich glaube, mehr Leute, die frustriert über sich zerstörungen sind und vielleicht dann weggehen. Also die, die weggehen können. In New York war es der Fall, dass der Times Square ausgestorben war, tot war, Kriminalismus wirklich hoch war Ende der 80er Jahren. Und dann hat man gesagt, okay, wir müssen was tun, sonst gibt es keine Leute mehr, die investieren. Das heißt auch wirklich Arbeitsplätze für Leute schaffen, die also nicht eine tolle Ausbildung haben und die sich entscheiden können, ich spiele mit, ich arbeite dort von, was weiß ich, morgens bis abends und habe eine Chance, hier etwas zu machen, ganz legal. Und das heißt, es war die Frage, ob Leute, die investieren wollen, Arbeitsplätze schaffen, entweder weggehen, weil die Substanz nicht mehr da ist. Das ist eine Sache, wo man nicht lange diskutieren kann, wo man nicht zehn Jahre warten kann, da sind die Leute weg.
Ja Sebastian, also ich sehe auch deinen Punkt, also dass natürlich die gesellschaftlichen Verhältnisse mittlerweile vielleicht an einen Punkt angekommen sind, wo wir tatsächlich vielleicht uns nicht diese Zeit nehmen wollen, mehr da nachzufragen, das kann schon sein. Aber diese Argumentation, die du gerade eben für die S-Bahnen und für die öffentlichen Verkehrsmittel und die dort eben stattfindende Videoüberwachung oder aufkommende Videoüberwachung bringst, die basieren doch eigentlich immer alle auf diesem Abschreckungsgedanken. Und dann wollte ich aber doch wirklich dann als betroffener Bürger, wollte ich dann eben die Rechnung präsentiert bekommen. Ich wollte wirklich erfahren, ob dieser Abschreckungseffekt der Kameras dann tatsächlich auch gegeben ist. Denn anders kannst du letztlich diese Argumentation nicht aufbauen. Es ist ja wohl nicht ein allgemeines Fahndungsnetz, um im Nachhinein Täter recherchieren zu können, sondern es geht darum, das im Ansatz zu verhindern. Und dann muss es natürlich ein Evaluationssystem geben, was uns nachweist, ob dieser Nutzen tatsächlich da ist. Denn sonst ist mir dieser Preis zu hoch, was die Grundrechte angeht und die Missbrauchsmöglichkeiten eines solchen Systems. Und da ist, glaube ich, ein Haken und da müsste nachgebessert werden. Ich sehe das bisher nicht. Stattdessen sehe ich tatsächlich die Fälle in der Zeitung, wo Jungs eben in den Bus und Bahnen sitzen und während die Kamera läuft, ihr Späßchen draus machen, trotzdem zu schlitzen. Und dann frage ich mich, warum soll ich diesen Kollateralschaden für die Menschenrechte und Bürgerrechte dahin nehmen?
Sebastian, eine Sache noch, da das auch, weil wir gleich am Ende sind und weil das ja schon eine grundsätzliche Geschichte von deiner Seite auch ist, weil du eine Geschichte gesagt hast, die mich ja schon so ein bisschen im Nacken kribbelt, weil du meintest, also wenn sich Leute gegen das System stellen, dann möchte ich da nicht lange diskutieren. Und diese Nummer mit dem System, sagen wir es mal so, da werde ich auch gerne polemisch, solange das System mich verarscht, möchte ich bitte auch das Recht haben, das System verarschen zu können, denn was wir hier bekommen, also das ist wirklich, es liegt auf der Hand, ist immer mehr der gläserne Bürger. Und was wir überhaupt nicht bekommen, ist der gläserne Politiker. Weil also das, was die Regierung macht in den Hintergründen, was da passiert, welche Gelder fließen, was, wo überhaupt...
Die maschinenlesbare Regierung.
Richtig, das ist alles überhaupt immer weniger vorhanden.
Das wird auch immer weniger geplant, dafür sind die Gelder nicht da. Und für alle Sachen uns zu überwachen, ist immer mehr Geld da. Das ist eine Diskrepanz, die mir nun überhaupt nicht gefällt. Und zum Beispiel finde ich es doof, dass gerade eben von Nils diese Stichwortkarten Abschreckungsmaßnahmen, diese Nummer, wie zum Beispiel Blitzer auf der Straße, das sind im Grunde keine Abschreckungsmaßnahmen mehr. Die werden ja so schön getarnt, dass du überhaupt nicht mehr langsam erfahren willst, weil die machen damit ja Geld, weißt du? Das sind halt solche Sachen, die mir immer ein bisschen aufstoßen, weil es ist mit einkalkuliert, dass alle Berliner so und so viel zu schnell fahren und schlecht parken, damit überhaupt der Staatshaushalt nachgebessert werden kann. Und solange das alles so ist, ja, möchte ich bitte auch meine kleinen Freiheiten genießen können und mich auf ein aufgeschlitztes Polster setzen dürfen.
Ja, das ist eine Freiheit, der preist mir zu hoch. Also ich möchte mich nicht auf ein aufgeschlitztes Polster beispielsweise setzen, weil ich mich frage, wie kann das sein? Weil das ein Unternehmen, was für die Allgemeinheit da ist. Und die Leute werden doch immer mehr frustriert durch die ganzen Zerstörungen und was weiß ich was, was natürlich ein gesellschaftliches Phänomen, was natürlich nicht nur hier...
Ist das wirklich das, was uns bewegt, Sebastian? Ich hab immer den Eichhau. Gerade in Berlin sind es 19% Arbeitslosigkeit.
Ich kann, ich kann aber aktuell...
Das ist aber das richtige Stichwort, ja, wenn ich das mal sagen darf. In New York gab es auch eine riesen Arbeitslosenquote. Aber die Leute haben begriffen, dass sich etwas drastisch und zwar schnell ändert und haben entscheiden können für sich, ich hab eine Chance oder nicht. Ich spiele mit oder ich spiele nicht mit. Und zwar nicht im Sinne von Duckmäusertum, sondern auch, ich habe eine Chance, etwas zu tun, etwas aufzubauen. Und das ist, glaube ich, eine Grundstimmung, die sich... Das mag auch sehr naiv sein, das weiß ich sehr wohl. Aber ich glaube, das ist eine Grundstimmung, die sich relativ breit machen kann, wenn man das Gefühl hat, es bewegt sich etwas. Und diese Frustration, dieses wie in einer Liebesbeziehung, das sind immer die kleinen Sachen, die anfangen zu stören. Das sind die großen Sachen. Dass jemand die Zahnpasta-Tou beoffen lässt, das sind nicht die großen Sachen, glaube ich, die frustrierend sind, sondern die kleinen Sachen.
Also ich kann zum Lesen empfehlen, gerade aktuell heute gefunden auf Spiegel Online, Kriminalstatistik, die gefühlte Bedrohung von Matthias Lore. Da geht es nämlich genau um die Frage, wie ist eigentlich diese subjektive Bedrohung im Gegensatz zu der tatsächlichen Kriminalstatistik. Irgendwie zu finden über Politik slash Deutschland findet ihr schon die gefühlte Bedrohung, wo halt mal genau dieses Sicherheitsgefühl auch ein bisschen analysiert wird. Sehr interessant zu lesen.
Sebastian, vielen Dank für den Angriff. Und das war eine gute Diskussion. Vielleicht zu guter Letzt noch den Lars. Hallo, Lars.
Ja, hallo. Hey, super.
Du bist der Letzte.
Ja, also zum Ersten oder zum Anfang mit so Chipkarten und so, die man so in der Mensa oder zum Zugang zu irgendwelchen PC-Pools oder so hat, hab ich als Student auch so ein bisschen Erfahrung. Oder dann auch bei diversen Firmen, wo man dann vielleicht schon mal so in Fan gearbeitet hat, zu Zugang oder halt auch kommen und gehen und was weiß ich nicht noch alles. Und dann wollte ich noch sagen, ich hab mal da, ich glaub auf Vox oder so lief da so eine BBC-Rapportage mal, da kam diese Sache so von wegen Verfolgen, was der Einzelne kauft, wurde direkt schon mal in irgendwelchen Supermärkten gemacht. Die haben das dann zwar nicht über solche kleinen elektronischen Helfer von in Chipform oder so gemacht, sondern halt per Videokamera.
Oder wie bei Ikea, wo die einfach Leute mit einem Blog hinterherlaufen und alles notieren.
Stimmt, das hatten sie glaube ich da auch noch mit erwähnt, aber es war vor allem, dass da wirklich Leute gesessen haben mit einer Videokamera und dann einzelne Personen, die sie sich vorher ausgeguckt haben, dann praktisch mit der Videokamera verfolgt haben und aufgeschrieben haben, was sie gekauft haben und in welchen Mengen.
Obwohl das mit Ikea, wenn du das mal wüsstest und du hast so einen hinter dir und du legst dann, entscheidest dich dafür und legst es dann wieder zurück und dann so hey, ah.
Mittlerweile fragen sie dich, glaube ich. Ich hab das mal in einer Reportage gesehen.
Ja und dann vielleicht noch ein ganz krasses Beispiel für den, da hat es ja eigentlich dieser Film gewesen hier, der Staatsfeind Nummer 1 mit Will Smith. Ja also mit diesem NSA, da irgendwie diesen amerikanischen Geheimnis, weiß jetzt nicht genau, wie der da nun steht, aber mit ihren zig elektronischen Hilfsmitteln und was sie dann halt alles in Bewegung gesetzt haben, nur um diesen Typen da praktisch zu verfolgen und verfolgen zu können.
Mein Lieblingszitat von dem alten, wer hat noch mal den alten gespielt? Der Alte? Nee, nee, nee, der Typ von der NSA, der ausgestiegen ist, ganz bekannter Schauspieler. Gene Hackman, richtig. Gene Hackman sagt dann irgendwie an einer Stelle, also sie haben 14 Quadratkilometer elektronisches Equipment unterirdisch und das war 1972 oder so. Ach, da kriegt man das Kribbeln.
Wie ist das bei dir, machst du dir da Sorgen oder ist das für dich eher so eine nützliche Sache?
Ich meine, wenn es intern bei irgendwelchen Firmen ist, also wenn es jetzt gerade um irgendwie Zugangsberechtigung, gerade wenn es halt ein bisschen so heikle Technologien sind, was ist nicht Halbleiter oder was weiß ich nicht, also wo dann vielleicht auch eine jede Menge Geld dahinter steckt, sehe ich es irgendwo ein. Oder auch, also jetzt gerade Mensa oder dass da praktisch mein, das Geld, was ich vorher aufgezahlt habe, abgezogen wird oder wenn ich da Zugang zu einem EC-Pool oder zu einem anderen Bereich habe, wo halt nicht jeder rein darf, mache ich mir eigentlich persönlich da nicht viele Gedanken. Also das ist für mich alles noch relativ verständlich und auch legitim, also da hab ich kein Problem mit, bloß wenn es dann…
Wobei da diese Beweislastfrage wieder ist, das schwört mir auch schon eine ganze Weile im Kopf, also auch im Zusammenhang mit EC-Karten ist jetzt was völlig anderes, aber auch gleiche Problematik. Was passiert, wenn halt das System nicht so funktioniert oder wenn da jemand absichtlich Missbrauch mit meinem Namen tut?
Ja, wo mir dann schon wieder so ein Klick gemacht hatte, war dann hier diese Sache mit dieser Carstad-Kundenkarte, die vorhin schon mal kam. Ich hab heute nun auch schon, oder auch wieder, jede Menge Geld praktisch zu Carstad geschafft im Sommerschlussverkauf und da ist mir auch so eingefallen, ja, das wird ja sicherlich auch irgendjemand analysieren und dann mit Namen und Datum oder so, dann wissen die ja, also wissen wir ja nicht wofür das dann praktisch noch verwendet wird.
Du hast mit Karte bezahlt?
Ja, und halt mit dieser Kundenkarte dann noch extra, die es da ja gibt.
Extra noch für Punkte?
Ja, ich glaube da gibt es irgendwelche Punkte, also das war die Karte von meiner Mutter, aber...
Gibt es ja eine Kaffeemaschine zum Schluss. Danke schön fürs fleißige Datensammeln.
Ja, das ist schön Lars, viel Spaß im späteren Leben. So, das war es wieder mit drei Stunden Chaosradio. Sehr fruchtbar heute, muss ich ehrlich sagen. Das war eine geile Diskussion und sie ging tatsächlich in mehrere Richtungen und war nicht nur die klassische, wir sind alle unzufrieden und hauen alle drauf, sondern es ging in mehrere Richtungen. Zum Abschluss, damit wir es dreimal bekannt gegeben haben, des Chaosradio gibt es natürlich wieder nur nächsten letzten Mittwoch im Monat, was bedeutet in einem Monat. Vorher gibt es aber das Camp, auf dem solche Diskussionen zum Beispiel auch weitergeführt werden können.
www.ccc.de slash camp slash 2003 vom 8. bis zum 10. August auf dem Acker in Alt Landsberg. Bringt eure Computer mit, eure Zelte, habt Spaß, besucht uns und kommt alle. Es gibt umsonst Strom, Internet, Wiese, nette Atmosphäre, viele Leute, Vorträge, Referenten.
All das. Im Studio waren Nils von der Humanistischen Union. Vielen Dank.
Tschüss.
Und Frank Rosengard von Chaos Computer Club und Max. Wir sagen Dankeschön, dass ihr mitgemacht habt.
Wenn ihr noch Sachen habt für uns, 84 at chaosradio.ccc.de, für Sachen speziell zur Sendung, allgemeine Sachen wie, irgendwie, mach doch mal Thema über eine Sendung über, dann bitte an chaosradio.ccc.de.
Ansonsten viel Spaß mit dem Night Flight mit Martin Petersdorf jetzt Musik zum Erholen von diesem Thema, das natürlich auch starker Turbak war.
Ciao.